in five
four three two
welcome everybody to the open uh
sedition
and uh the eve of the civil war podcast
um we were actually sitting down to do a
normal episode
that we had planned here and i just been
watching the news and like
pretty disturbing stuff so i wasn't
really just prepared to come sit here
and talk about that jeffree star
apparently gave kanye west a blow
which is shocking by the way almost more
shocking than the news but
not quite there let's talk first about
the news and then
[Music]
so this is really impromptu live
but uh we felt like this was the only
way to do it so what is happening
is that basically magda country spilled
out
they stormed the capitol and
um they're basically rioting they spent
the past four years crying about
protesters and rioters and people taking
these during football games
and now they're literally riding and
destroying
the capital i love it
trouble and you know trump is sitting at
home with a bag of popcorn just washing
it being like
this is this is this is good they love
me they really love me
um he's such a he really at this point
i mean at this point can someone just
walk him out and just be like yo
it's time you're done you're fired there
there's literally
over 3000 americans dying every day
there's hundreds of thousands if not
millions of vaccines sitting unused in
shelves
because there's literally no leadership
yeah
i know that this guy is out on the 20th
but every single day now at this point
that he stays in
is is killing americans it's
perpetuating the spread of kovid and
it's eroding democracy
and now this whole this whole the maga
the maggot right of 2021
is uh is the cherry on top their shots
fired
they're breaking here let me anyway
trump apparently put out a video
after being silent for an hour let's
watch the video i haven't seen it we got
a video yeah this hit this was just
issued eight minutes ago i have not seen
this yet
i know you heard we had an election
that was stolen from us how do you know
what's happening
how do you expect people to respond okay
and you know the problem is that when
you it's it's not only donald trump's
fault it's every
republican it's every media personality
that perpetuated this absolute lie that
the election was stolen
you could not you can't you know i was
watching the georgia runoff yesterday
and they showed polls that seventy
percent of white voters in georgia think
that the election
was unfair and
how can you tell these people when the
country is being stolen from you that
the election was stolen
how can you tell them to step down these
uh well i don't know what else he's
going to say but this already is not
helping
i love this yeah
five seconds collection and everyone
knows it
especially the other side dude you're
trying to de-escalate
de-escalate de-escalate de-escalate
get the [ __ ] out
you're trying to go on the escalator you
have to go home now
we have to have peace wait wait how are
why are they supposed to go home and
have peace when there's literally
what you're saying stolen yeah uh what
how is peace possible when
like if you believe that the election
was stolen like that how is peace
possible
right right because that what he's
saying is that they've
committed a grave act of treason and
stole the country
so how if you believe that can there be
peace
he also knows exactly what he's saying
you know in between the lines
he when he's he's like yeah i do
genuinely think that he's happy this is
happening
yeah we have to have law and order we
have to respect
our great it's too late for that people
in law and order
we don't want anybody hurt it's a very
tough period oh yeah and by the way
i know i'm sorry sorry i keep pausing
but [ __ ] this guy
[Laughter]
you know they're all about blue lives
matter and [ __ ] and then all of a sudden
they have one clash with the police and
they're burning their blue lives matter
flags
it's like these guys are literally
hypocrites made of [ __ ] uh
they're made out of sawdust they have
the backbone of sawdust
they have one spout with the police and
now they're burning their blue lives
matter flags
and by the way these people out there
these mega people are out there as if
like there's been black activists gay
activists who have literally not had
human rights
the right to vote the right to get
married and have actually
suffered under real oppression for years
and these
[ __ ] get are under this assumption
that the election was stolen and now
they're storming the [ __ ] capital
like as if
like they don't understand what real
oppression is like i understand if your
life
sucks and you're you you don't have
status you don't have wealth and
and that because class class issues
is is the biggest problem i think in
america right now is that you're poor
and you don't have any
hope and any chances but like
that's not what this is
this is just i feel like they all just
feel like
i'm the big boy i'm going to grab my gun
and i'm going to show
them yeehaw
squeal this is mega country now
the earth was created six thousand years
ago and if you don't believe that you
could say hello to my
shouty that's his shotgun there's never
been a time like this where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all where's the part
where you tell them to chill
you from our country this was a
fraudulent
election you he is so insane play into
the hands
of these people this is basically a call
to more violence
so go home we love you you're very
special
you're very see what happens you see the
way others are treated that are
so bad and so evil i know how you feel
but go home and go home at peace go home
listen they are evil they are so bad
they did steal the election
this has never happened before they are
utterly evil
they deserve to die
but go home i think what's just so dark
about this
is that we just came off of the whole
black lives matter protest and we saw
how those people were treated stopped
and they were
actual peaceful protests killed manned
it's just so painful and these magic
guys are literally storming the state
capital
and i i just can't stop national capital
thinking about what it must feel like
for a black person to be
watching this a white guy can just go in
there with a gun and a confederate flag
and
be like yo i'm just i'm just a peaceful
guy
look at me mom i'm sitting in the i'm
sitting in the uh
the house leader's chair they broke into
nancy pelosi's office and left a note
for her
what's going on ian what's the update
because i heard last night the national
guard was being
called in uh yeah they're
they're deployed as of what like 30
minutes ago or something is there any
compelling video should i put it on
not yet i sent you a video of the crowd
if you wanted to just come okay
keep me updated let's let's see what's
video of the crowd let's see what's
going on out there
and i love they all have their maga
flags you know exactly who they're doing
this for
this there's there's no way to spin this
or to twirl this around this is trump's
army this is his mega army
attempting to overturn a
fair election
i love it
why what are we waiting for if these
were black processors there'd be blood
in the streets
it'd be biblical wouldn't it
and that's what it said there'd be
that's in this [ __ ] what's so
sad about this country i just
there'd be body parts under the treads
of tanks
what are you supposed to feel like in
this country as a black person
when you're treated like that and white
people don't that's just insane
i mean there's not even gas being shot
you know there'd be gas
blue lives matter oh [ __ ] the police
he's like excuse me you can't come in
[ __ ] the blue lives matter flag's on
fire
[Applause]
this is like right now ian pretty much
uh i mean yeah within the last you know
40 minutes or so boy
yeah they've infiltrated every basically
every
area of the capital they're in the
senate they're in the house they're in
the speakers they're in all the offices
there's like priceless art there that
i'm sure is being vandalized and
destroyed
there were shots fired man
you know i didn't actually expect this i
thought it would just be
just throughout this election on
election night and everywhere it's
always been like
everyone's kind of expecting this but it
never really went there
and um
and so i was kind of expecting more of
the same of just like hey you know
but this is this is crazy i mean and you
know trump basically there's this great
uh this trump tweet from basically while
all these riots were happening
i'm not logged into twitter uh damn
donald trump twitter and he basically
was like
we need to hang the vice president
well listen let me let me tell you
mike pence who has no power to stop this
at all
trump has been preparing to throw him
under the bus basically and throw him to
the wolves
for months and he
can't mike pence cannot do anything and
so i don't know why
trump keeps hitting this home like he he
wants people
he wants he's trying to get him
assassinated
and now finally on the floor while the
riots are happening he says
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country
it's like mike pence is in the building
where there's rioters breaking in
and he's basically saying yeah you could
you could
you could kill him he's a coward he
doesn't have the courage to do what he
had to do
i mean this is dangerous [ __ ] am i am i
overreacting
no let me answer my own question
i think he's got to go i think trump
talked to the president that way
yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you dude you're not president for
much longer and hopefully not any longer
after today
somehow i doubt that but it shouldn't be
is anything else in here i should watch
ian
oh here's the last thing on our discord
just in case you guys were wondering
so yeah
so ian just let me know if anything i'm
just sending you
you know stuff that's being sent to me
um it's a video of
cops taking pictures with protesters oh
let me see that
it's in there it's all in there
it is because it's just it's kind of
hard to differentiate
because it's all just maybe you should
you should fish it out you know
where where is this happening oh here
and this is our discord chat i'm writing
little descriptions under everything you
don't see cops taking selfies with
protesters inside the capitol
it's just oh i see a whole mess of
out here let's see cops really taking
selfies with protesters
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding me
hey
what do you say i mean what can you say
this person is a writer
oh my god they're a writer
why hey cap hey calf
hey calf hey
let's be on disturbing by the way give
his badge number 1828
not that anything will happen probably
get a promotion wait i think i see in
the chat
it says baked stop being a [ __ ] that's
probably baked alaska's scream
you know that guy i mean i've heard of
him what about him oh that's his stream
i'm inferring that from the chat that
was on screen
so what's more unbelievable all this or
the fact that uh
jeffrey starr apparently had an affair
with kanye west i mean it's a really
close one
i mean unexpected maybe jeffree star is
more on unexpected
yeah it's definitely more unexpected
this was very expected
yeah jeffrey starr broke up kanye
it's rumors and i'm just gonna say that
ian what's the chance what's the chance
that
jeffree star gave kanye blowy
i'm not really buying into it you don't
believe it
jeffrey also tweeted today going i'm
ready for sunday service which seems
like
he's playing into the meme a little bit
okay but he went to wyoming for sure
he wrote in the lyrics that he sucked
congratulations well if he's been in
wyoming then he
must have [ __ ] well why else do you
well to be no i mean i do as silly as
that sounds why would jeffree star go to
wyoming
i have a top sample sticker on my shirt
here
um sister i don't know i think that ian
is a little bit compromised on kanye
stories i'm just saying the person who's
started this rumor licked the toilet
seat because she said kovid was getting
more attention than her
so he also doesn't have the greatest
track record if i may say
who what does that mean the person that
started the
t that's going on well well i choose to
believe it
but they're definitely getting divorced
right ann i just saw yesterday an
article that they're getting divorced
right also hasn't been confirmed yeah i
saw i believe
you know what i i'm so over kanye i just
feel bad for the family and the kids
you know but the good news is ian you
have a chance with kim now
i am very happily in a relationship
right i forgot i forgot
wait we were saying he lives in wyoming
jeffrey
he has a house no he's not hey since
when does jeffrey live in wyoming does
he have another house
i think he purchased a home yeah yeah
he's definitely having an affair with
kanye anyway
you you bring me updates as they're
happening but this is disturbing stuff
man
i don't know how we're to go to
inaugurate inauguration i think he needs
to just get the [ __ ] out
you know it's funny i was watching fox
news
i can't believe what i'm seeing this is
just such a dark day
it's like you spent the last
months crying non-stop about how the
election was stolen and how it's a fraud
and how we need to investigate
of course this is you're reaping what
you sowed and
seriously everything that's happening is
on the hands of all these people that
bought into this pure
[ __ ] fantasy that there was
anything but a fair election there's no
evidence
none but can you just find like 12 000
votes
somewhere okay
um you know this reminds me like when
you quit a job but you still have to do
like two weeks
and every day so oh trump
so painful yeah he hasn't been doing
anything he literally
he doesn't do anything we have a
pandemic
we have a vaccine you know what the
vaccine reminds me of you know it's like
all these pro-lifers that go
we we advocate for every baby's life the
minute that baby's born they can [ __ ]
starve i don't give a [ __ ]
but while they're in the womb because
you know they like they don't give a
[ __ ] about welfare and poor people
right and social services so they're
like i want this baby to be born into
this totally broken
[ __ ] up family makes sense
so so what what it is happening right
now is uh
what the vaccine is like they fought so
hard for the vaccine
and now that it's here they're like i
don't care what happens to it
um do you not think the fall of
democracy
deserves cracking open a beer cheers
from ireland
cracking open a beer probably does
cheers from ireland
also we got uk person here what's going
on he's like oh nothing
well here let's do a recap because a lot
of people may not see can you send me
like
some key pictures and videos in so we
can kind of show people what's happening
because there's been a lot three why
aren't you calling the rioters
terrorists well yeah
i mean rider is pretty strong terrorist
right they're right well terrorist i
don't really know i don't and you
couldn't i guess
they are theirs i don't like them that's
for goddamn sure
[ __ ] them dude they're terrorists [ __ ]
them dude
okay we got all kinds of media let's
explain what's happening here
so ian can you explain i don't know if
you're doing stuff in chronological
order if you're just sending me [ __ ]
that's happening now i need a little
more explanation
i'm just giving you live you know you
just said live links
um and a little description in there
trying to keep on top of it so
is someone gonna okay so this is from
one hour ago
they're trying to steal it they're
talking to themselves
they're like stop the steal what do we
do
we're chanting stop this deal and we're
trying to steal it
their heads are going to explode from
the irony
yo i want some historical stuff so
somebody do that
who's doing that what kind of stuff i
want stuff that was leading up to it i
want stuff that happened so people who
don't know
you got a historical like paul revere
stuff like that
no there's a bunch of links in here here
the one that i just linked is
uh you're all linking in the same chat
it's impossible to understand what's
happening here
i mean they'll okay maybe just click
let's just go one by one
open the links this one has um this one
is the cops uh
letting them in to storm the capitol
building
police are squabbling with protesters oh
there we go
they let them in did they just do that
because they didn't want to get
stampeded and they just reached the
capitol again
bro what what i'm not sure that
qualifies this squabbling
i mean so i guess i can understand
there's only like five
cops there why is there so little
[ __ ] security here
that's what i'm saying the mayor of dc
asked for national guard to be there
because they knew this was going to
happen there's literally i see four
prepare for this
i'm assuming they just let them in
because they didn't want to get
stampeded and they just reached the
capitol again
um apparently pence unfollowed trump on
twitter
what is that the level wait is that real
somebody fact check that
so pence i will say because pence was in
there and he's getting thrown under the
he's getting absolutely thrown on the
bus by trump
um and so i'm not surprised that he's
just
over this whole charade of acting like
but he was inside there he was he was
ready to get hung up
he said peaceful protest is the right of
every american but this attack
on our capital will not be tolerated and
those involved will be prosecuted to the
fullest extent of law
the violence and destruction taking
place at the u.s capitol must stop
and it must stop now anyone involved
must respect law enforcement officers
and immediately leave the building
it says he's still following him yeah
i've seen a lot of big
other big creators like our friend james
charles tweeting about it
but what [ __ ] idiots just check it
before you tweet it dumbass
james charles by the way
dumbass i'm not logged into twitter so
have a hard time
navigating tweets but let me look at
what james
charles
is tweeting our friend in the beauty
community
not mike pence on following and changing
the header of
what the [ __ ] you talking about he said
he changed the header to biden and
harris is he kidding
no he did he did change it to biden and
harris he did
yeah i'm on it right now i'm on his
profile what
oh he did what that's
that's that's that's mike pence yeah
that's mike pence in his wife
i was like that doesn't look right god
you people are so cold
like why would mike pence do that like
the nation is in crisis and he's on
changing his header on twitter like i
was like bro this country is more [ __ ]
up than i ever dreamed if mike pence is
on twitter right now changing it better
it's priority
return of the jedi moment right there
like you coming back oh my god
people think he did unfollow but then we
followed
sorry that's not what mike pence is
thinking about right now i guarantee you
there's no chance that he unfollowed and
re-followed welcome to the
misinformation of our life donald
trump's about to put a
press conference out lis mike pence
unfollowed me on twitter and this is an
act of
of uh of treason
mike pence is a big friend
yeah there's this one i don't know
people are saying he did unfollow him a
few moments ago why would he unfollow
and follow i've refused to believe it
he has a personal account as well oh
good there's uh joey
cam grants so i don't know if you guys
saw there's somebody who stormed the
capitol
and sat in the chair and cam grants put
joey sells ping in his mouth
you know joey salads would be in that
mega
group totally and he might actually do
that because you know he's attention
yeah that's awesome crazy jesus top is
like
almost too real cam grants is a legend
he's so good
oh wait joey got banned off at twitter
that's right i was like i'll go check
his twitter
he's gone she always lost it all right
okay so wait we're having okay
we're getting oh there's articles of
impeachment being drawn up now
excellent from elon omar donald trump
should be impeached by the house of
representatives and removed from office
we can't allow them to remain off it's a
matter of preserving i mean i agree you
know what
okay check out what ivanka said oh
ivanka
oh let's see what this dumb dumbs up to
send it
by the way if you want a picture of
nepotism and [ __ ] like
you have no business being governed
you're the daughter you're the
president's daughter like who the [ __ ]
are you to talk about anything
anytime the president's children open
their mouth to say anything i'm like
who the [ __ ] are you look how beautiful
she is
have a quick update james charles
deleted his tweet
yeah okay good there you go peaceful
protest is patriotic
violence is unacceptable must be
condemned in the strongest terms
so what am i okay but you guys are they
continually
encourage these people but then they say
like oh
what happened i just was unacceptable i
just spent four years
talking about how yeah the whole
government
is rigged against us and they're faking
elections
if that's true if that's true
then how can you not justify violence
right yeah if you're if you supposedly
want it was stolen yeah if
people believe that's true except no one
has confirmed that like literally no one
[Music]
i mean the georgia state is run entirely
by republicans
you know what i mean pennsylvania i just
dropped you a link i guess uh they are
busting out the tear gas now
okay this is what i want to see this has
been waiting for these [ __ ] to
get a little [ __ ]
real treatment here chaos in washington
wednesday
as scores of supporters of president
trump tear gas on capitol hill
let's go why does every maga bro look
the same elections
police fight clones they're like storm
troopers government buildings to be
closed
as protesters you know what's funny man
i was watching this they're all walking
within the [ __ ] ropes
like the vast majority i was like yo
just put red velvet ropes out front they
wouldn't cross the line
look how polite they are inside after
riding and breaking in
closed as protesters marched through the
halls of congress
the chaotic scene the viking guy was the
guy that actually got into the uh
seat that joey was photoshopped in yeah
i saw that guy
at the uh at the you know it's great i i
really do believe all these people are
going to be arrested
i hope so because they're all they're
taking photos they're putting it on the
internet it's like
you're going to jail you're going to
jail the chaotic scenes came after
president
donald trump addressed thousands of
supporters near the white house
and someone monitoring his baseless
claims what's up with the chat
yeah chat being chat trump was the best
exclamation let's get them to call in i
want to talk to them
i'm serious you're you subscribed to
spam pro
you just paid me five dollars to come
spam pro-trump
chat that's amazing
please more pro-trump people come pay me
to spam i love it
oh my god
that the election was stolen from him
due to widespread fraud
election officials of both parties and
independent observers
look how dirty this guy's beard is
put your beard bro bro you got more
problems than democracy being stolen you
got like
a whole meal in your beard election
officials of both parties and
independent observers have said there
was no significant fraud
in the november third contest which
biden won by the
seven million votes in the national
popular vote
the unprecedented security breach forced
both the house and the senate
to stop proceedings temporarily
suspending a
last-ditch effort by pro-trump
republicans hey ted cruz
[ __ ] you should sit in the chamber and
greet your friends who you encouraged
ted cruz is spearheading this whole dumb
[ __ ] thing to
to protest the election yeah
go sit in there and greet your friends
these are the people that you
that you encouraged
man ted cruz is really such a piece of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that guy dude al franken has the
best saying about ted cruz
he says when i was in congress
i liked ted cruz more
than most of my colleagues [ __ ] i always
[ __ ] it up
no he hated yeah more more than his
colleagues and they all hated him no no
no i liked ted cruz
this is awful yeah yeah no it's awful
but it's so good
that that it's really not that good
i think it's so good but i can never get
it right you're just saying basically
everyone hates me everybody hates ted
cruz but it's funny
that way he says it somebody looked that
up i did i like ted cruz more than most
of my other colleagues like ted cruz and
i hate ted cruz thank you
great al franken everybody we love to
hear it
hey dan that's not bad
vice president mike pence who was there
to preside over the joint session of
congress
was escorted out of the chamber by
capitol police
as a safety precaution there has been
tear gas
in the rotunda members of the house were
urged to take out gas
masks secured under their seats and to
be prepared to put them
on as officers stood at the doors with
guns drawn
to prevent any protesters from entering
meanwhile outside of the capitol
building
body armor-clad members of militia and
far-right groups
filled the streets with some chanting
pro-trump slogans and clashing with the
police
this is a city-wide courtroom well what
does it mean when you bring the
confederate flag to are people so
[ __ ] dumb so can you explain to me
like
it's just plain racist right that's what
it means the confederate flag
uh i don't know so yes i think so the
confederate
of the confederacy broke away from the
america yeah because america
basically there was there was a lot of
friction between the north and south the
south was all plantations and slave
ownership
and in the north there was like a huge
movement to liberate slaves
and it was all industry and so there was
all this friction growing like
slaves would run away to the north
because they knew they'd be safe there
and the north had a policy of not
returning the slaves to the south
so there was all this friction over that
and ultimately
the south decided to secede from the
nation they said you know what [ __ ] it
we're gonna go make our own country and
abraham lincoln was like nah dude that's
not how this [ __ ] works
so they went to war and basically it was
um
over slavery and to preserve slavery for
sure
so what so you know the confederate flag
represents
not only slavery but full-on treason
against the american government they
lost
they lost their traitors they
formed their own union they lost the war
they wanted to tear america apart and
they got [ __ ] owned by the north
and uh so when you fly the confederate
flag you're basically bottom line you're
racist
you're you're extremely racist i mean
the flag to african americans is just a
symbol of oppression there's no other
way to interpret it because i saw people
say like the fact that the
confederate flag made it inside yeah
that building is
just it represents a return they want
the confederacy is all about
uh slavery for sure
you know but they're also [ __ ]
traitors
that openly rebelled against the
american government
you know so there's that oh confederacy
is
is trending let's see what people are
saying about the confederate
oh here you go trump and what do you
need to know man like if you
if someone like this has my name on a
flag
i'll be like yo that guy's not with me
he said he loves them and they're very
special
they're very special you got to sound
bite that zack
they're very special you got it they're
very special find people on both sides
stand back and stand by remember that
right this is what they're doing they're
standing back
and standing by oh boy this is why
confederate statues should be removed
their [ __ ] traitors they don't
deserve statues bro
they're part of history not statues are
meant to be celebrate or
are monuments of reverence to be
celebrated
[ __ ] confederate generals should not
have military bases
named after them they're [ __ ]
traitors we don't make
military bases and named after timothy
mcveigh
he's a [ __ ] they're [ __ ] traitors bro
like it's oxymoronic it's it's it's so
stupid
that we even tolerate this weird
reverence to confederacy and confederate
generals and [ __ ] it's just
it's it's insane you know
people tried flying confederate flags or
putting up monuments to confederate
generals after the civil war they would
have been [ __ ] put in prison
dom fox heritage
unbelievable man
[ __ ] the confederacy
come on pig
we down here yeah that's that's going in
the history books
yeah that's what i saw people say like
this is an image they didn't think
that's going in the [ __ ] history
books
they really love their vests this is a
really good caption he says
during the four years of the civil war
the confederates never got closer to
washington than fort stevens until today
when insurrex's supporters of donald
trump paraded through the u.s capitol
building carrying the confederate battle
flag
we love you you're very special
yeah shit's crazy
just in awe i i i wasn't gonna be able
to do a show today because i was just in
front of the tv and i was like well
we're gonna just have to go live and
talk about this
is there anything else what is this one
is this what i just watched
i don't know if you guys said there was
guns drawn there was definitely someone
shot we were watching the news live and
they brought some woman we saw the video
yeah they just like it was on live we
can't walk they were not even talking
about
the image and they were talking about
something else and on the screen you see
someone like fully bleeding from the
neck
yeah it looks like they were dying tons
of blood everywhere i was like what the
[ __ ] is that
i just watched on this live feed and
they're going on and on prattling about
some [ __ ]
i'm like uh what the [ __ ] was that it's
probably good that they don't
to be honest well they didn't rile them
up even more
supporters of president trump stormed
the capitol hill in an attempt to force
law i think i
just watched um we got here
amir i'm from a third world country and
this
still looks really bad
god bless the united states of america
leader of the free world in every
possible
yeah earth's reality god help this world
is led by us
we ain't the leaders of the free world
anymore uh no i don't think so i don't
know who is
should have a college historian on the
phone to explain the confederacy
well i think much more than slavery
sorry
wrong it's [ __ ] slavery it's not
there's nothing
i mean i mean i think we got the general
idea i don't need a [ __ ] historian
bro
trust me there's [ __ ] racist pieces
of [ __ ] that wanted
slavery they don't want to be told what
to do by the north
you return my slave there yankee
so i can bring him home and give him 20
lashings
on top of what ethan said it's so ironic
that those traitors
support the confederacy and trump and
they
both yeah they can't is anyone tired of
winning yet are any of the trump
supporters tired of winning yet
they lost the senate they lost the house
they lost the presidency
he is such a [ __ ] loser trump
literally
ruins everything he touches yeah whiny
little
i'm tired of winning ian just put a
pretty good clip in here thank you ian
what do we got here
protesters have breached the capital
they're outside the senate is this oh
this is the whole thread
that was the first moment they entered
yeah there was a video i don't know
oh there's a video i just see pictures
here might be down
this one here
well there's a lot of stuff from igor
here
so yada yada protesters are on the third
floor of the senate walking door-to-door
where the [ __ ] are they oh that's
really cool that reminds me of like
knocking on the doors where the [ __ ] are
they yeah i don't think they hung around
the confront
[ __ ] maga country beautiful though
the chambers are really nice
in that nice floor nice roof
all right if you go down just one or two
more on the thread the
the video or here's the infamous photo
of this clown
hey everybody get my face on picture i'm
going to jail
i'm sorry but this just shows like trump
being such a weak leader i mean
these people shouldn't be able to get in
there first of all well
it doesn't matter if they're in your
favor or not
he literally he literally i know that if
he cared he would have put people there
i know i think he thinks this is good
for him but it to me
it just looks pathetic this is the
downfall of trump yeah
this is it doesn't make you look good
no you look like a weak leader all the
people that were tiptoeing towing the
line behind him just
[ __ ] cow towing to all of his magga
supporters because they want to get
reelected
nobody's been able to defend this
anymore
yeah here's a video
jump he blew it
[Applause]
you look pretty ballsy man
at least that guy's got an american flag
no you know what i mean if i could give
him some credit
but it's like look at you guys what are
you doing
it's so ironic they literally lost your
mind
they wanted to they wanted to lock
people up and
what did they say when the looting
starts the shooting starts trump
tweeted that out because people were
like stealing diapers from target
and this is bad this is fine
it's crazy dude we love you we love you
especially very special
okay great so here's the scary moment
when protesters initially got into the
building from the first floor made their
way
outside the senate chamber
[Applause]
we love you you're very special
we love you you're very special
oh why is there one there's like yeah
this poor
dude these officers
[Music]
dude it's one cop bro just like you guys
need to be prepared
dude just just save your ass yeah
why are you chasing the cop back the
[ __ ] up dude
there's one cop i mean what is this
failure
this is such an embarrassing failure
dude this guy needs to go to jail
wherever this psycho is yeah
you have a bean bag in the [ __ ] face
you probably have a bullet in his hand
he was really sad to me i feel like
the officer had to put his mask on down
because he has to yell
part of his self defense oh yeah of
course i mean like
might have gotten culvert too on top of
everything
dude this guy oh my god what the [ __ ]
what do you want dude
very special guns out dude guns out
[Music]
this is so stressful yeah day of
wrecking will come
is this what papa was talking about
he knew every papa knew everything
damn what else igor's got some good [ __ ]
what else you've got for us
what's going on igor igor
oh this was his last tweet i actually
just sent you a
video of um the battery ramming
the door down
oh can you find me the video i saw them
erecting a giant cross
can somebody find me in that video it's
just so odd
i mean is that some clan [ __ ] or is it
just like weird
well like why did they bring a giant
unless they start burning like they
brought like a
hunt like a 500 pound cross like this
enormous piece of wood
here
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm just so happy that there's a trump
sign on it and everything everything is
plastered and trump just
so you all [ __ ] finally know that
there's no doubt left who these people
are i don't know they still doubt
they're they're apparently nc found
undercover
yeah i i saw no people are saying it's
antifa
yeah yeah all those people are antifa
[Laughter]
these don't look like antifa these are
mega boys through and through
they got the doc they duck calls in
their pocket
they got the suez no people aren't
saying that this isn't they are
definitely saying
people say that on twitter yeah i've
seen there's oh no
i can i can't do that i can't even do
that
that's not antifa
we sent you the cross video it's in the
discord i can't you gotta find me antifa
stuff i i can't what's like what's all
these usual suspects who are always
[ __ ] defending
trump and saying it's a steal like
crowder and ben shapiro saying
uh good question let's see what mr
shapiro has to say
ben shapiro what would ben shapiro say
about this right now whenever i
type ben shapiro on twitter the
suggestion is ben shapiro wife
what is that i don't know is it a parody
account here what is it oh here here's
an
ass p word is this so you're telling me
this is antifa
that antifa brought a 500 pound cross
from washington extra hard here
i mean who does this this is next level
psycho [ __ ]
this is what jesus would have wanted
jesus told me to storm the capitol
now let's light it up and show them
whose box
[Music]
free victory victory they're bringing
christianity back baby
i'm tired of this war on christmas
that's right
the war on christmas has gone too far
so i brought my own 500 pound cross
now jim bob where's the gasoline we're
setting on fire now suey
[Laughter]
oh yeah we're antifa by the way for sure
bill montgomery who no do you have any
food how do i follow that
can you guys stop saying call joey
solids
call joey salad that's not happening
it's like the jaw rule meme
what does joey salad think about this at
a time like this joey's always gonna say
this is not false advertising
uh yeah this is um i don't know
i wouldn't call that protest i would
call that trade
trader traitorism i would call that a
false advertising
no now's another time ja rule
meanwhile in los angeles trump
supporters are holding a rally at la
city hall um what the [ __ ] does that
have to do with anything
so they're in support of what's
happening i'm assuming
yeah well at least they're not at least
there's just standing there
and that's fine and i don't think it's
good that they're they're supporting
what the [ __ ] going on in the capital
but
it's saying multiple fights are breaking
out yeah and
that was not really the time because
what they're saying like okay protesting
is obviously fine
but when there's when what's going on in
the capital is going on
it seems like they're out there
supporting it which obviously is going
to be
inciting a lot of people to be angry at
them
i mean it makes me angry to see people
out there
[Music]
it's kind of like you it's just like
look you can't prove anything
they but they know everything they cry
about antifa
for years and look who's antifa now
look who's the actually no look who's
the
[ __ ] they're just the [ __ ] they're just
the facts
i like someone who's saying it's antifa
and discord
you found someone oh let's go
let's see okay here's
a looter stealing a post that wasn't it
it's the link above that that was a
funny picture it clicked
and getting a shot tear gassed and
thrown in on massive
wait wait wait
oh right yeah look
he's like hey it's nice to be white it's
a nice podium
what a great photo why are you looting
why are you looting the capitol i love
how he's just smiling like
he's like hey you know where to find me
my mom is going to love this podium yeah
yeah the uh the link right above that
one is the uh
dante for conspiracy yeah and it's uh
it's quite a take i gotta say all right
let's see
the hot juicy yeah uh
the right okay this is awesome let's see
riot shields are dead giveaway this is
antifa i find out laughable that
anyone's calling these people trump
supporters
laughable
that anybody would believe these people
are trump supporters this is a
quarter of a million follower account
saying this by the way
that guy's not antifa bro that guy came
out of a swamp to be here
you know what i mean i find it laughable
anyone believe this antifa
oh yeah
he's definitely antifa bro look at this
guy
this guy just came from a clan rally bro
i definitely had t for boards
trump supporter would never do such a
thing
now light that cross on fire that we
brought that 500 pound fraud
oh someone said uh cynthia said that
quest is literally what the kkk does
yeah that's right that's a pretty clear
picture of who these people are i agree
that seems very clanny
to bring a crush and erect it i mean
that seems very clannish
like who the [ __ ] carries a 500 pound
cross
like that's straight up you've got the
confederate flag you've got the giant
cross i mean the only thing you're
missing is the robes here
sticky torches and tiki torches as they
all know
all good white supremacists carry tiki
torches
can i get a come on now piggy
[Applause]
yeah that's definitely in tufa i'm sure
the comments are good on this
yeah i'm sure at tfed its finest
man it's crazy
i love it this guy's going to jail
well i don't know i don't know because
trump thinks they're very special he's
not going to be president for much
longer
you're very special he's like i love
this image just
trump you're very special it looks like
he just received that compliment
like he's just so happy to be looting
the capitol
go ahead trump tell him what you think
you're very special
he's beaming um we love you
you're very special a super chat saying
ben shapiro retweeted your boy
dave portnoy
wait what did dave fort noise say let me
get it
you know i love him let me meet some
dave portenoid
95 percent there's some horrors in this
house i'll give it to you
right
i also linked to video they're starting
to use flash bangs
let me watch the capital good also um
golden girl in super chat said you see
in most videos that most don't have
masks
on of course not only does
most news outlets got their face on
camera but
they'll be complaining when they get
sick
the people who back the blue are going
to be arrested by them
um they don't block the blue after today
i'll tell you that
they really thought the police were
gonna like throw down their weapons and
be like we're staying with
we stand with the confederacy now light
that damn cross on fire boys
oh there's no sound i guess
yes give them the treatment these are
rioters
send these [ __ ] back in
you know i i've always felt like new
years doesn't start until january 20th
because there's just too much tension
there's too much [ __ ] i just want
trump and all this
[ __ ] people to shut the [ __ ] up sit
down
i want trump gone january 20th then we
can actually
hit this ground and have a fresh start
i just want someone to actually be in
charge
to [ __ ] deal with this pandemic all
these people are angry because of the
pandemic that trump has
propagated and mismanaged there's
literally millions of vaccines
sitting on a shelf
now they say i'm immune
[Applause]
that looks like a bunch of antifa to me
bro it's laughable that anyone doesn't
realize these are all antifa
[Applause]
let's see what portnoy pork boy
what did pork boy tweet
so ben shapiro retweeted pork boy who
said
95 of people in this country are normal
i mean sure
the extreme right sucks and stream left
sucks both sides
why are we trying to do this like all
sides yeah
like now why are we doing all sides
right now
both sides filled with lunatics crazy
and morons almost all politicians are
hypocrites
who manipulate these idiots for personal
gain and no i won't run for president
i'd rather
trust me nobody [ __ ] wants oh dave
dude you host a podcast with an 18 year
old child
you're nobody's trust me nobody's
looking for you to run for president
dude now is not the time for this all
sides [ __ ] it's so
[ __ ] disingenuous yeah
let's just talk about what's happening
it's not all sides are
you know what i mean like you're right
that all sides have lunatics inside
and crazy people this is not all sides
moment
nothing the left has done pales in
comparison to all this [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] outrageous it's like that's
the only you know this is the only way
that people like ben shampiro
can like admit that what's happening is
[ __ ] up they have to do all sides
it's like yeah mega is storming the
capital and looting it
and violent but all sides are crazy so
i'm not gonna i can't just criticize
them i have to criticize
all sides so they can say [ __ ] face
it's funny how he talks about how they
manipulate idiots for personal gain
what the [ __ ] is ben shapiro and all
these idiots doing
they literally can't who cannot
openly criticize rioters
right they spent their whole career
talking [ __ ] about writers and now that
it's happening it's all sides
it's all there's some horrors in this
house yeah there's a [ __ ] in this house
ben shapiro you
[ __ ] you little weasel
reading that it was mike pence who uh
authorized deployment of national guard
trump that's awesome because it just
i mean awesome in that it shows what a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
trump refused to issue the national
guard that's the report that i read that
i retweeted it seemed from official
source
that people were calling for the
national guard to come in and trump
refused it
and then pence had to step in
how's that even real i think you should
go to jail
he's such a corrupt [ __ ] there are no
lives in my canadian city protesting too
for some reason
someone said the canadians was like damn
this ain't nothing to do with y'all so
secretary of defense
confirmed it was mike pence not trump
who authorized appointment of national
guard
i mean wow
[Applause]
what does that mean that trump that mike
went behind his back because like
doesn't does he have the authority to do
that unless trump's been like
you know what i mean yeah exactly uh
trump is busy watching the news
not now mike i'm watching the news the
acting secretary of defense confirms it
was vice president pence and not trump
who authorized deployment national guard
damn that is a stunning
development stunning
yeah really yeah what to make of that so
the report i read was that everybody
around him in his cabinet was begging
him to issue a stronger statement to
issue the national guard
yeah they said that on cnn they said
that there were
he's just watching the coverage and um
because it's all for him his team is
asking him to say something stronger
like
to ask them to leave the building and he
refused they all
allowed this to happen you know so if
pensa did that it could imply that he's
been like removed right
it does it does i mean yeah there's that
implication because
there's like the 25th amendment they can
they can do an emergency
yeah they can essentially so but the
fact that that pence did that is curious
yeah he doesn't have that authority
really
and you know putin's watching like this
is it baby this is the best day ever
let's go
look at this tweet i just sent
jaw rule we got your rule oh god this is
perfect
on my way to dc to sort the [ __ ] out
what
[ __ ] yeah ja rule what
oh
[Laughter]
he said it's not fraud he said the
election is legitimate he's um
well it's just false advertising right
right
i would call that uh false advertising
capital building with weapons drawn on
trump supporters that breached
[Music]
i'm taking off the screen because the
video we saw earlier of the girl getting
shot was
at the store really yeah i didn't show
anything
no i'm just i don't know where that
video is going oh it's done that's
it okay yeah that's not
fraud i want to accidentally show that
thank you dan
you got it you got it dawn
i mean seriously is this not enough to
just
walk him out of that office i think it
is now when his own vice president is
like
yeah this guy's sipping diet coke and
eating
french fries and i gotta call into
troops
that's just i don't even know what to
say about this is historic you know
nothing like this has ever happened what
we're witnessing now
is history in the making right now this
is
never nothing like this has ever
happened and so
i think we need to appreciate the moment
we're in
this is history right now
now let's light that cross on fire yeah
boys
yeehaw now i love it
has jeffree star said anything yeah
what's jeffree star saying about all
this it's
not a why it's too easy or maybe i'm
wrong
yeah it is jeffree star has said i'm
ready for sunday's service from two
hours ago
i find it funny people were just
tweeting as if nothing's happening
like people are like hey yeah check out
my
uh here's a cute picture of me and my
dog
uh dude would you let uh zach would you
let jeffree star give you a blowy
no no look at this comment i thought
kanye was bipolar not bisexual yeah well
apparently he's
i could see i see can seek on you
goodness i can
dude all right what do you think about
this whole kanye stuff ian are you still
on board with kanye
i mean what's going on you've been off
no
are you just off or like what i'm
just going to keep looking for news
updates really
no comment
here's a video uh can you send me this
video
cops helping mega down this the steps
this guy rex chapman
what was that what are you huh oh it's
zack so apparently they said on fox news
unlike the black lives matter protesters
there's no vandalism
other than the breaking into capital
other than the ones they're really
smashing the windows and taking the
podiums and
you know oh my god
it's in the it's in the chat there's
that's incredible
news oh here's another good one from
deaf noodles ian you should check all
that [ __ ]
hard-hitting reporter deaf noodles i
like deaf noodles
keep the media coming so the cops are
helping
maga rioters down the steps to the
capitol
and this you know they're doing this now
after several hours that these people
have been out here
uh let me let me help you down my lady
oh yeah
take my hand my lady if this was black
lives matter are you done uh protesting
ma'am
okay let's see yeah let's let's let let
me help you down the stairs
now after several hours that these
people have been out did you get
anything nice any paper weights or pens
or anything
nice i'm glad you had a free victory
victory victory victory
let me help you out there man excellent
i hope you had fun
don't forget a commemorative pen out of
nancy pelosi's desk
maybe a podium
just sent you a pretty juicy clip oh my
god the one ian just sent
here i'm gonna open this they record
george floyd's death at the national
capital city church
these are nazis exercising their white
privilege to show how much they really
hate us
so what is this
they're reenacting it oh really
wow they're reenacting what
george floyd yeah these people aren't
racist
what the [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] this is
this just makes me nauseous
i know that this is very serious but can
i also ask what is this person wearing
why are they leopard print vests
they love their vest dude why are they
so angry i just don't get it
why are they so [ __ ] angry
like who why would you celebrate another
person dying i just don't get that
so here was uh by the way is this
um this this lady is this the weird q
anon lady
who's this lady because she was giving
some weird so this morning
as the writing was starting this lady
was out here praising hitler
listen to her this is a congress lady
bill montgomery who
uh was uh instrumental in getting
turning points
up and
right
hitler was right on one thing he said
whoever has the youth has the future
hitler was right really yeah
why would you even quote me it's
according to say what whoever however
youth has the future she couldn't find
someone else
on one thing he said whoever has the
youth
has the future oh my god our children
this woman
just said why even bring him up yeah
he'll be right on one thing
wow that's all jews
he was right on only one thing boys
it's been a good run democracy has been
a great one
but here we are on the steps of congress
our elected officials with here it is
ready
was right you heard it here oh my god
this is uh mary miller
mary from illinois so she's the one that
was speaking
yeah all jews
all jews thank you keemstar hitler was
right on one thing
what was he right about gamestar death
to all jews
keemstar's very he's with it you know
oh this is so [ __ ] depressing
this is such a forced quote because it's
such a common quote that the future
generally exactly it's like you were
just you really tried hard to bring up
him
whatever it's really not such a unique
quote right it's a very basic concept
to go to the hitler was right how
[ __ ] dare she i'm sorry
i mean how can you even have those words
in any sentence that comes out of your
mouth
especially hitler was right
just you know thousands of [ __ ]
americans
died fighting nazis oh my god
dumb [ __ ] what like what like jewish
ancestors like
like [ __ ] you like seriously like [ __ ]
yourself like that's
awful you sound like antifa to me
actually it does sound literally like
antifa you and people i'm like every
time i hear antifa anti-fascism i'm like
i'm anti-fascism
i am anti-fascism that does sound like
anti-fascist
hitler quote was not in favor of hitler
what was that supposed to mean well
okay [ __ ] genius she said he was
right about one thing right
why bring him up doesn't matter it's a
very
basic idea she communicated no you do
not bring him up and you don't have the
words come out of your mouth that hitler
was right about anything
that's just i'm sure he was right about
lots it doesn't matter
why bring him up like other people it's
like saying uh ted bundy
he said hello to me once and he was
right about that ted buddy was right
about one thing
you have to be distrustful of women or
whatever don't trust women
you know it's like you you're
normalizing praising hitler
yeah he was right about this one thing
and maybe this other thing
let's talk about hitler and the other
good things he's done mm-hmm
maybe he's definitely all jews he was
right about that and sorry about that
maybe he's right about this
shut up [ __ ] her
and if you support her [ __ ] you too
don't answer her because we need the
revenue what she checked out a copy of
mineconf
what the [ __ ] is this what are they what
is this
white trash [ __ ] what are they
smashing
camera equipment from the news oh yeah
cameron [ __ ] antifa
i also smash everything inside they hate
the media
news media is this antifa
it's like auntie for the these people
don't understand they're such a [ __ ]
hypocrites
oh my god i could just die of the irony
there's no vandalism happening
all they did was break into the capital
brother not a nightmare what's going on
is there
is the is the national guard breaking
the [ __ ] up like what what's happening
they have been called in i haven't seen
any videos
showing you did someone got the news
open like a news feed
uh i can let me open up uh
all they did was break into the capital
unlike black lives matter
[Music]
well uh there's a curfew at six it's 5
30 right now
and so we'll see what happens 30 minutes
that's probably when they're going to
begin
yeah exactly send aien to the capitol
hey ian you prepared for battle air
he did disappear i don't know where he
went so oh can someone pull this video
off
could somebody pull this video of mitt
romney being harassed in the airport
from yesterday uh sure i'll try and find
it he was just sitting there minding his
own like oh my god i
felt so bad for him
[Music]
is this interesting or no
what
oh yeah you can read i don't give a [ __ ]
it's funny you are live making money off
of this but you said silent when antifa
and blm
were burning cities down and destroying
businesses what
cities were they burning down i don't
understand what the [ __ ] city
why are you doing a what about like dude
we weren't
silent about those uh protests by the
way we were very much in favor of them
in favor of them of burning down
businesses no not that
of the black lives movement yeah he says
burning down cities
and businesses not in favor of that i'm
saying we weren't silent
about it but they're the [ __ ] they're
doing is so greatly exaggerated why are
you [ __ ] comparing them first of all
thanks for the 5
dumbass and second of all
why are you comparing them they're
storming the capital
can you just focus on that which is way
[ __ ] worse than anything a t4 black
lives matter did
dude come on bro it's like anybody who's
aligned with the trumpism
they're just they're having like this
terrible
they're having to confront what this
this terrible thing that they're a part
of and so it's just turns into what
about ism well you guys did this so now
we're doing it
sorry bro you gotta reckon what the what
your people are doing
i ain't [ __ ] responsible they were
planning to take hostages
wait what how do they know that
oh they have zip ties oh my god dude
that is so [ __ ] wait what is that for
surprise for taking hostages oh
my god you just posted that
uh dc police say they've so far made 13
arrests
13 that's it yup well i don't know how
easy it is to arrest people right now
because there's like 10 cops apparently
there's like 10 cops in the entire
capital
oh dude
i'd love to talk to people who are like
want to argue
i want to argue with these [ __ ] bring
it on dude
got any callers that want to argue get
on discord
this is more significant than a city and
comment to what the other person said
also like dude you can't like
okay like george floyd wasn't like
antifa
or any organized it was just a [ __ ]
there was there was
some rioting because people were so
[ __ ] angry and that happened
sometimes
that was like an emotional response to
this great injustice this is an
organized
effort to interfere with democracy
like bro don't even [ __ ] talk to me
about the whataboutism
yeah shut up dude use your brain it's
not the same thing
the united states of cuanon
look at that antifa man these guys all
look like their parents are related keep
referring to
the viking dude as the queue shaman i i
guess he's like
a known figure with the queue movement
or something this people are supposed to
be taken seriously
yes like i said they look like their
parents are related
trump is my president and my mom is also
my sister yeah
is that possible to have your mom be
your sister i think so
you think about it
is my president not for long
[ __ ] can we cut through again
okay so so here's so i don't know if you
saw this hilo
this happened yesterday because mitt
romney is one of the very few
republicans who's willing to actually
stick to his [ __ ] principles and be a
reasonable human being
and this is what it means to be a
republican as far as i remember is that
you disagree
you have different ideas about how the
government should be run in the policies
of the government but you're a decent
human [ __ ] being that believes in
democracy and the american experience
right and so now mitt romney because
he's standing against trumpism and mega
he became a target and people have been
harassing him here at the airport this
happened yesterday
how you doing how are you doing
don't tell me what to do please put your
mask on it's it's required by law in
this airport oh she's got no
ice cream oh my god okay i'll tell you
what because you know what i'm going to
go ahead and do it because i'm going to
have a chat with you
why aren't you supporting president you
support the things that president trump
does
as if he's obligated to support
president trump is he's not
you're not supporting him i'm sorry i do
agree with many of the things he
is for and i support those things are
you going to support him in the uh
the fraudulent votes this is the
election no no why not
i'm sorry can you say that again no not
really
it doesn't work for you the
constitutional process is clear i'll
follow the constitution and i'll explain
all that
well you haven't supported him and you
didn't even support him in the election
no i did not why um he just answered you
you were voted in as a conservative to
represent the conservative
constituents how the constitution period
it is you're voted in to represent us
you work for us
so am i wrong i work for the people of
utah
exactly and i am from utah well but
you're not really one
i voted i know there's a lot of people
that didn't vote for you exactly you
didn't vote for him so what the [ __ ]
dude
he won you admit it you know it you know
it's coming
they didn't want you in there anyway so
to be honest with you i wouldn't be
surprised if
if you weren't even if you
i mean i know it's weird to praise
someone like just for
i mean look when you're in a party
that's been taken over by people like
this
i feel like we need anything anyone that
will just stand up like a tiny bit it is
going to be
praised unfortunately it is courageous
to do what was the bare minimum like you
know
we don't need anything so you feel like
i [ __ ] i really appreciate
romney i like mint
i like him god bless him
god bless that man in his magic
underwear he's a warm he wears
magic on the way he wears magic
underwear what does that mean i don't
know something mormons do they wear
they wear magic underwear to ward off
the demons or some [ __ ] i don't know
god bless him
right you weren't eating why is the
people that call themselves the master
race look like someone took a piss in
the gym pool
took a what in the gym pool a piece in
the gene pool oh yeah
yeah of course all the master racers
look like totally [ __ ] inbred
it's crazy
so yeah so far the dc police say they've
made 13 arrests oh god
i live in seattle which is referred to
as a burned
down city yeah there was one day of
looting and the rest was just firing on
non-violent protests
exactly that's what i'm saying seattle
is one of these towns that was
apparently burned to the ground by
antifa there was people living on like
one
strip of street in this entire city
it's really not burnt down to the ground
dude
it's really not i feel embarrassed i
thought trump could make positive change
the response is terrible by trump and it
sucks that citizens could die tonight
for that
i just don't want to be grouped with
this crazy people
yeah i do think there's a lot of people
that at that time
there was a certain magic about him and
a lot of people thought hey
why don't give it a shot maybe maybe you
could make a change
i don't know i don't blame you for
voting yeah i don't blame you for
thinking that at the time
you shouldn't feel guilty for voting for
him it's like you just have to
you just have to like be willing to
accept that even though you voted for
him the guy is just not
doing the job and he's dan you know what
i'm saying like you don't need to feel
guilty for voting for him
there's nothing wrong with voting for
him he's a republican you report the rep
you support the republican ideas i mean
that's fine you know what i mean
it's also okay to just say like hey that
was a mistake
you don't have to go down burning with
this cold now you know because you voted
for him and i'm glad i'm actually glad i
feel like that's a great
statement you made and i feel like
that's just that's the appropriate way
to respond it's like i voted for him
he's not he's this is not okay and and
and i no longer support him you know i
mean you're not responsible
there's all these [ __ ] people like
ted cruz and all the people
on fox news and all these media
personalities that pretend
these people are smart they know there's
no fraud they
know there's no [ __ ] fraud
right it's these people
the chair of the blame
oh are you kidding me what else we got
no news huh i mean are they still inside
the capitol what's going on
uh i don't know for sure but i think
that uh i i saw a little bit ago
just a tweet not a video that um swat
teams were
moving through can you send me a live
stream i just want to put on like
some news coverage and see what's
happening live uh
yeah one sec let's see swat team
interesting
trish is texting me oh let's see what
you're saying
i just sent you a news feed there you go
and discord
oh good hopefully we don't get popped
yeah you sent me a news feed thank you
let's see
this time last year around the state of
the union for a slim moment i thought
that trump
might have done some positive in regards
to trade and economy but
in the past past 12 months is completely
blown
yeah you know what like i thought so too
like to give trump some credit
his [ __ ] he china is so out of control
and he did a good job
you know reigning in their ip taking
that
issue head on with their ip theft and
everything
and somehow jared got in there and
normalized relations with israel and a
lot of countries in the middle east
which is good for everybody
but ultimately you know
just been it's just
i don't even know what's the word look
he's proven himself so many times by now
to support the wrong ideas
to not stand up against the wrong people
and it's just unacceptable at this point
it doesn't matter if he had a good
couple things that were good
it just doesn't matter at this point he
doesn't want to be tyrant he doesn't
want to give up power he's done
everything
the first time that he really just i saw
the evil in him was when the tiki
torches came out
and he said there's good people on both
sides right when he didn't have a strong
statement
against that yeah i've never seen that i
feel like
you know in israel there's always things
happening and it doesn't matter the
leader has always got to be
saying the right sending their good
message a unifying good message
standing up he's here against the bad
people you know who the bad people are
yeah and the fact that he couldn't say
just a clear
message that was the moment for me when
i was like wow
like that's just unacceptable the thing
is um
and it was a long string of doing that
like
shouting out the proud voice stand back
stand by
yeah and he was really just
fermenting this he was building for this
to happen and
this is what he planned for if people
dared to vote him out
he was going to burn it down they have
been told that the capital is now
secure oh good side at least and that
they should now get back to fulfilling
their duty
of certifying the 2020 congress is going
to get back in
certified entire capital complex is now
secure that is pretty remarkable because
there are
an endless number of corridors and
offices and nooks and crannies and
hideaways that would need to be
checked to ensure that where were these
[ __ ]
three hours ago inside this complex
before all this [ __ ] went down we have
been seeing images
all day long of it's unbelievable that
they weren't ready for it
members whatever you want to call them
toting out podiums we saw one guy with
his feet propped up on
nancy pelosi's desk oh yeah um you know
so so people
clearly sent you something pretty spicy
got something coming in from dan oh no
what is this a noose outside the capitol
building
well really these people aren't racist
[ __ ] dude what the [ __ ]
just imagine like that's sad just
imagine preparing for this
like that's a lot of preparation of and
thinking ahead
this guy has an unfortunate last name to
be tweeted oh no his name is john lynch
john lynch you can't tweet about news
you should yeah you should have sent
this to a friend or something
damn john lynch ugh
this is so [ __ ]
i mean look
i just hope this is it you know my hope
is that
they had their fun they could cause
their trouble
they go in they certify the vote and
this is it
i don't know if this is going to be it
though because there's going to be
inauguration day
trump's got to actually leave the
[ __ ] white house he's got to
physically
leave the white house right that's a big
if
complex but uh i'm still tripping on
this report that pence ordered the
national guard
yeah that really uh does not
make sense i mean is he in charge now
gathering in their offices every way you
look at it is very disturbing
to happen next the one person we haven't
heard from at all
is senate leader mitch mcconnell [ __ ]
[ __ ] he hasn't come out anywhere
and spoken on camera since his speech on
the senate floor
earlier this afternoon and of course
we're all waiting to hear what he has to
say and what house speaker nancy pelosi
has to say
about what's going to happen next we're
just now hearing um
some kind of announcement over the
loudspeaker here in one of the senate
office buildings it's a little bit hard
to make out
this is so dystopian and we're seeing
individuals about this impending
curfew but this is the first time we've
heard a message like this
inside the office building today
you're in the russell senate office
building nancy which is uh
to the just to the north of the capitol
um hey one question you mentioned we
hadn't heard from leader mcconnell
have we do we know that whereabouts of
speaker pelosi and do we have any sense
that
you don't want to say where she what are
you doing we have
not gotten any information from their
aides about
where exactly they are where they were
taken initially
and where they are now look at this guy
absolutely no information in fact
you're gonna have to force me to move
leader mcconnell you know where nancy
pelosi is could you
uh can you share where what address
she's at yeah
and what kind of security detail she has
yeah office itself
i think that there's no question that he
we are now just ten minutes away
from the dc curfew at six people the
curfew's gonna be
shit's gonna be crazy you can see the
police all right let's check back in at
seven
apartment six six is the curfew yeah
should we talk about something else
until we have ten minutes until the
curfew ends
jeffrey kanye jeffrey kanye i mean the
only the other biggest story in the
country
well you could go through those rare
insults yeah
oh yeah hold on nancy we've got to break
away reports are coming in
that jeffree star kanye west of blowy do
you have more information about that
olive garden wow sister snapped
yeah why is olive garden trending hila
oh i'm going i'm not talking
yeah i saw it in the car
olive garden right there oh yeah let's
see what olive garden
oh
anderson cooper said they're going back
to the olive garden and holiday end
where they come from to discuss this
i think he was bashing on him
to olive garden
people hate olive gar all right you guys
want to talk about super coveted super
spreaders or
people [ __ ] on me on rare insults
you know which one we want to look at
we've had enough depressing stuff today
you should read some
uh comments i see a lot came in
oh i need to someone read comments i
mean yeah somebody should be
looking at the comments i won't be
talking maybe you want to read some
comments
yeah i have some ones from a little bit
from earlier but uh
read those amanda for 25 said send the
f soldiers to dc miranda
they don't want to deal with the foot
soldiers but thank you yeah they don't
want that smoke
yeah uh miranda for 20
said i'm a psychology major and i'd love
to talk to you guys about the psychology
behind cults i feel like some of it
really applies to the people who
genuinely like trump
well yeah i agree it's definitely very
cultish
sierra for a hundred dollars said thank
you she's not here but
like you're an amazing person
damn she paid 100 bucks for that neil is
not even here uh what you said was very
true and thank you for keeping us in
your mind it's disgusting what people
get away with it's a slap in the face
for sure
we'll tell eva we'll make sure she gets
the message
um rebecca for 10
said i became a member today just
because of this mayhem this is literally
a sedation and an attack on democracy
and they're calling it patriotism
i don't understand those supporting this
crap i think they're going to lose a lot
of supporters today i hope i mean
because look the whole congress was in
there republican and democrat
you know ted cruz had to slither his way
out of there
someone donate a hundred bucks and say
they love you
here i said ela you're an amazing person
well you said it was very true don't
need to tell me that [ __ ]
thank you so much that's really sweet
thank you
i'm gonna donate 100 bucks you're
amazing i'm gonna donate two hundred
dollars
you're amazing person yo donate for me
dan
markell for ten dollars said hi ela i
love your hair color i'm going to try
and get it that way any tips for that
particular color i also love the teddy
fresh
um thank you i don't know here's a girl
um
i basically started with um it's really
bleached like it's super light
um and it was kind of too yellow on the
top
and then um i wanted to cover all the
yellow and go gray
and to cancel the yellow we had to put
in it purple so it just became kind of
like a mix of purple and gray
and that's it happened to you
i got knees we don't like the police
anymore
i just decided i don't like the please
go inside
i made it like a foot inside and they
pushed me out and they amazed me
oh what's your elizabeth i'm name
knoxville tennessee and what's your
address you want to go in
last night it's a revolution
oh really oh the revolution stops when
you get a faithful amazing
little bit of peppers you're ready for a
revolution
and you bitched out in a little maze man
you [ __ ] was soft bro
thank you what happened to you pathetic
losers [ __ ] them
it's a revolution they spray me in
[Music]
someone said about me hey abby keep
reading the comments about like
conversation starters you know what i
mean
not so much comments just if they have a
point or a conversation or a question or
something you know
um but if you have more just just just
read them out
no a lot of them i had were about joey
salads really what are they saying about
joey
everyone keeps saying uh get joyce out
to go to dc and report on the situation
yeah right joey would [ __ ] joe would
make things way worse so you'd show up
in like a
he would find some way to make this way
worse
you know what i mean he would show up
like dressed up as antifa and start like
breaking kneecaps and stuff just as a
social experiment
so somebody said about me ethan looks
like he controls the flow of cigarettes
through a max security prison
that's kind of a compliment that's kind
of like bad that is i gotta say
so funny
well the no eyebrows definitely [ __ ]
me up yeah
but apparently people just were should i
click the folder ian or should i just go
through these
do i got how many likes 17 000.
oh my god what ian oh yeah you can click
the folder if you want
yeah okay so ian put together
guys half your size or why i have a jet
guys your size or why my ex-wife has a
jet thank you
that truly is the best that was one of
the best burgers that was brutal papa
john's that was brutal
dunked on me dude i saw some people in
the comments on
on the comment were confused they
couldn't understand the meaning
oh because the meaning because i was
i was he was calling me fat yeah i was
like papa you sell pizzas you're the
reason i'm fat
and he goes okay well you know
it's like guys half your size are enough
to make me
have a jet yeah and then guys who go
your size
there isn't my ex-wife also saying that
i'm very fat i eat too much pizza
i really like papaya
come on papa you know yeah
let's see ethan yeah uh ethan
probably thinks the civil rights battle
of our time is the right to
all day breakfast after night 10 30.
that's true that's [ __ ] up
when you're pulling mcdonald's and
there's no mcmuffin i'm ready to storm
the capitol
i'm ready to erect a giant cross outside
the capitol
we the man oh damn it come on foreign
mcmuffins
ethan looks like the egg that carried
the virus in osmosis jones i don't get
that reference i need to see a photo
oh what the [ __ ] why is that such a rare
reference
oh my god you know that movie got
such bad reviews but i liked it i think
a lot of people like that movie yeah
i remember i went to see it in theater
and i was the only one there
that's the only time it's ever happened
to me i was moses jones yeah
that's hilarious i think ethan got stuck
in the feeding window the way winnie the
pooh got stuck in a hole in the rabbit's
house
this might be true i left the feeding
window wide open
ethan is turning into the moon emoji oh
that's true
i gotta sue i gotta see the moon emoji
moon emoji emoji
this is me
just a fat round face no eyebrows
there's something about the eyes why
does ethan look like a spy kid's two
henchmen
ethan looks like what gerd feels like
true
ethan looks like some eastern european
low-level thug in a tech
taken movie that's dope
ethan looked like dave bautista's cousin
with autism davis
davis batista oh my god
ethan looking like the simpsons fake
michael jackson guy oh that's pretty
good
i look like like my neck is massive
i mean come on guys i shave my hair and
eyebrows off give me a break
he looks like he has a manifesto true
that's good
he's built like penguin from batman
return
why has no one mentioned how ethan looks
exactly like the bar
woman in shrek oh my goodness
oh yeah i've seen that that is really
good
that is so identical yeah it's crazy
wow while casting directors i am
available
i like how ethan makes fun of other
people's looks when he looks like he
should be selling bootlegged dvds in a
romanian flea market
oh yeah this is pretty straggling so
oh i see this is this is from this video
ian
or did you just fish this photo up no
that's well that one's from that video
yeah
fair enough he looks like mar from home
alone too
when the pain fell on him and he was
electrocuted yeah my hair was wild
oh god look at that eh he looks like the
full body manifestation of
unwanted dick pic true
that's really good
that's really good oh people are saying
it's curfew time
curfew is up ethan has the body of a
funhouse mirror windex bottle
what very specific all right time to get
moving boys
the curfew's out lack of respect shown
today for
our institutions appalled
by the reckless behavior of some
political leaders
that is a rebuke of senator ted cruz
that's a rebuke of senator hawley am i
incorrect in reading it that way i i
just think that um and if i remember
it should also be noted that um
president george former president george
w bush yesterday
put out a statement that he would be
attending the inauguration
of president-elect joe biden a signal
that
he believes a peaceful transition of
power should occur
he does not put any weight into the
trump is so [ __ ] dumb he wanted
pence to just overturn the election what
facebook completely deleted trump's
recent video what was his recent oh the
one where he was like
they're very special special people
really how about the leaders account
i love you you're very special well it
it it's
it's contributing to the problem you
just tweeted again one minute ago
trump yeah exciting these are the things
and events that happen
when a sacred landslide
election victory so unceremoniously and
viciously
stripped away from a great patriots who
have been badly and unfairly treated for
so he needs to leave
go home with love and in peace remember
this day forever
he needs to [ __ ] be gone now these
are this wow
so he's saying this is this you brought
this is what happens yeah
these are the things that happen when a
sacred land side election
he's he's basically thanking them
pretty much this is [ __ ] horrific
wow go home with love and peace peace
and love
with peace and love i shall be arresting
all rioters
dude this is horrific warning you with
peace and love
this is [ __ ] this is just horrific ringo
is warning you with peace and love
area 51 is trending area 15 people are
saying
storming the capital building was like a
million times easier than the area 51
except there was only like my brother
went there there's only like five people
there
they're also saying we should sneak into
area 51 while they're distracted
this was pretty much an endorsement of
the writing
right which is just insane
man he's such a con man he's just got to
keep them
he's got to keep them in the cult
because he's leaving office
and he wants their money he wants their
money donations he
just wants their money you gotta work on
that 400 million debt
dude this is how the gop
and all these people supporting him
really i
you can't just pretend not to not to
this is [ __ ] insane i can't believe
this street
peace and love remember this day forever
damn thank you thank you gringo what do
you think about this tweet
the woman who was shot has
so who was she what happened is there
anything is there any info can you guys
look
uh she seemed to be one of the people
that stormed the building and uh
from the video that i saw she appeared
to get shot in the neck so i'm not
totally surprised that she that was so
crazy they were just watching live and
they
got carted away and they were just like
and then
you know mitch mcconnell isn't that
[ __ ] he was getting the scoop on this
story looking it up too
woman dies after shooting in u.s capital
yeah basically she was shot when they
were getting in the building
right how dare they
surprise i am surprised that not more
people were shot
to be quite honest
well they're white um if there's any
other statements by people i'd love to
hear it
man facebook deleted facebook facebook
too
mark zuckerberg's got blood on his
[ __ ] hands [ __ ] mark zuckerberg
[ __ ] him dude all these people have been
flirting with this fascism and all this
totalitarianism and now everyone's like
so shocked
that trump is basically openly
thanking rioters frame antifa is the
enemy of the state to openly thanking
writers here we are folks
magga this is what mag is
[ __ ] unbelievable [ __ ]
but that they were essentially using
procedural blanks that it wasn't live
ammo
and his point is actually it was and you
should have known better
and not only were you in cautious but
you are partially to blame
for that which we have seen play out in
the united states capital
quite obviously a set of circumstances
none of us in our wildest
and darkest imaginings could have
imagined
one of the um
one of the scenes that we saw today was
not only members of the house but
members of the senate
on their knees with gas
masks on with bags over their heads
as they watched capitol police
guns drawn trying to push back
protesters
on the phone is congressman
congresswoman susan wilde
she is a democrat from pennsylvania
and congresswoman tell us what
today was like for you it was a very
emotional
and difficult day it still is
it possibly the most frightening thing
that i've ever gone through in my
lifetime
and um it was uh a day
that will will last in our memories for
a very long time um
oh my god that is so good for
how it started
how it's going dude that is amazing that
pho
that is amazing i can't like it i'm not
logged in
oh boy what a [ __ ] up picture look at
this
damn this nightmarish
yeah it really is we love american
democracy except when our guy loses
the constitution the constitution says
the vice president can overthrow any
election he wants
oh yeah so i was saying trump it doesn't
make any sense he wants
he wants the vice president to throw
single-handedly throw out the election
results and people actually support that
notion
what is the point of having a [ __ ]
democracy when the vice president could
just be like nah
ladies and gentlemen of congress nah
okay i guess he's staying like
that what it means for the future
assume the business at hand of approving
the electors
um i would like to see
the objectives withdraw their objections
but i'm quite sure
someone on the stream said something oh
she's like something about the tweet
anyway
let's see we have um you guys know that
pope francis liked another
model's ass pick as we wait for more
news
you guys heard the story about pope
francis like that brazilian girl with
the big ass
and they launched this whole
investigation and everything
we're actually working on getting a
stained glass oh that trump tweet that
we uh
read yeah twitter didn't remove it
but they have uh locked it down you
cannot reply
retweet or like it well
just [ __ ] delete it you [ __ ] yeah
they did that with this video too
just delete it then it's so yeah
wait what is this but you can quote
tweet it you can quote tweet it
perfect good job i mean what
it's the president like what are you
supposed to do he's the [ __ ]
president of the united states
tweeting [ __ ] that here let me show it
sorry he's the president of the united
states
quoting [ __ ] that's [ __ ] inciting
violence so what are they supposed to do
and he's still the president right so
like on one hand it has this historical
value he's the [ __ ] president
right i know but everyone already got
their screenshots we know the tweet
happened
it's just if you're gonna lock it just
delete it
and then same with this video yeah we
all got a copy of it at this point so
you're saying facebook erased the video
huh
that's what eric dr deng tweeted
that facebook deleted it what off
dude this tweet is like next level [ __ ]
this last one
very special very special
man he's masked off today isn't he
so anyway i was saying we're getting a
stained glass window of pope francis the
ass he liked
on instagram and so it turned out pope
francis wasn't done
i mean look a lifetime of virginity you
know gets you thirsty bro
gross fancy's instagram account appears
to like another model's racy pick
this one here he likes thick women i'm
noticing
although he is he is uh he's latin
american yeah he's latin
and i know they like them thick down
there
he's like oh look at this i love this
post he's like
like to get a bite of that the way they
edited it yeah
so apparently i don't know if the church
is even trying to explain this [ __ ]
anymore
you know what i mean the vatican said it
was asking instagram for an explanation
insisting we can con we can exclude that
the light came from the holy see
yeah somebody [ __ ] somebody was
jerking off in the vatican for sure
very nice
let me look on my twitter because i feel
like i've got
a ton let me play this i'm gonna look
for good [ __ ] on twitter because i feel
like i've got
vote we should once again just let
everyone know
that the dc curfew is now in effect
the the law enforcement
has enforced the
securing of the united states capital uh
you can see law enforcement has cleared
the west front of the capitol they have
been told that inside the capitol is
secure and yet the lawmakers are still
secluded and kept in this secure area
although a group which we're not going
to say
republican senate objectors or those
that we're planning to object today are
now meeting
separate from the rest of the senate
they were being held in a holding room
um we're getting pool reports of
reporters who split up to
monitor the place and one of them tells
us that uh senators
uh braun of indiana indiana cruz of
texas
josh hawley of missouri and others are
meeting in a separate room together
outside of the larger room with the rest
of the senate speaking you think these
guys love
are they still gonna do this [ __ ] i
feel like they do because they're like
they're like so deep in yeah he's still
gonna get up and talk about fraud and
yet and yet the words
it's like when you block in the poker
game but you go all in
right you're like i'm gonna lose
everything and i should block
yeah totally i've been there so many
times institutions are traditions
and our law enforcement he called this a
congressionally mandated meeting of
congress
and that it should move forward and not
be um
be inflamed by falsehoods and false
hopes in his
words so the senators that ed just
referred to have a very big decision
turkey apparently uh who is uh basically
pretty close to an autocratic country by
ergodyne
has made a statement erdogan air gowan
whatever [ __ ] them
he's a douche no matter how you cut it
they're putting out a statement we are
following the concern and international
development happening in the united
states
we call on all parties in the us to
maintain restraint and prudence
this is coming straight from ergo
de dong we believe the us will overcome
this
internal political crisis in a mature
manner
we advise all turkish citizens in the us
to avoid crowded areas and places where
protests are taking place
you know the only time i've ever seen
that is when we were in like thailand
and that you the government issued a
warning for american citizens to steer
clear of protest areas
awesome now that's america
gotta love it eh are they fueling that
which we saw play out
unimaginably and grotesquely in the
capital but couldn't they be fueling it
if they don't do something at this point
if they don't
follow through with at least some of
them these people come right back
tonight
and try to do it again yeah that's going
to be part of the calculations
potentially
yeah there is a way to describe what
would be happening
i mean you thought about this crazy we
now say that
it has fueled something that we consider
to be out of control and uncontrollable
we are going to stick with the
constitution we ask you to do the same
and if you don't
you will be in violation of the law and
the spirit
of not only federalism but
constitutionalism and
we new york times has some photos here
observers in the capital donned escape
hoods and shelter in the house
as a mob stormed the building and
breached the senate chamber
oh god that must have been terrifying
and they were like what is going on
those are pretty sick not as cool as
ours
what's with the baggy that doesn't look
that secure the contraption looks legit
but what's with the baggy
huh that looks high-tech man yeah it's
interesting
bro what the [ __ ]
oh that's antifa you could tell by the
bright shield oh that's true
right
that she has sadly passed and so
that's crazy i can't believe we saw that
has led to a confrontation with
law enforcement and capital could have
been worse she could have gotten
one death multiple arrests and also
multiple others
transported to hospitals for a number of
different
injuries but we have that update for you
at this
hour there is also because of something
from ian's coming in
paul gosser trying to walk back his call
for election audit who's paul gosser
uh oh is that the is that the guy that
had funny
videos who's the ghoster
you got back here's the guy where his
whole family like made it
yeah they all hated him oh he got
ghoster
yeah right you gotta go search right i
forgot about what a ghoster is
what was it his whole family was
campaigning against yes
this is awesome it's the best thing ever
you got ghosts okay
i said let's do an audit let's not carry
it away here this is from three hours
ago so this is kind of like
early hour oh my god look at them
scaling like goddamn z up in this [ __ ]
look at these zombie ass [ __ ]
rednecks bro
the joker's there
let's not carry it away here i don't
want anyone hurt we are protesting the
violation of our laws we are builders
not destroyers black lives matter
burns and loots we build no apparently
not
negative if anyone on the ground reads
this
and is beyond the line come back nice
job goes there you
save the day
your whole family hates you yeah
crazy it was awesome the gozer
oh i don't know i'm gonna step away from
this
some guy chilling in pelosi's office
this was good
yeah feet up on her desk so disturbing
i mean this guy's going to go to jail
right you better
support the president are seen sitting
in the office of house speaker nancy
pelosi
and they and many others breach the u.s
capitol on wednesday
by 3 pm riders were using ropes and
makeshift ladders to reach the north
side of the capital
although far more simply walked far more
simply walked around the corner and
reached the building's outer walls on
foot
that's funny they're like some [ __ ]
were using ropes other people just
walked
i love it is he got a gun in his hand
looks like a rifle where
oh he's a rifle am i wrong
it's definitely some kind of weapon i'm
not sure i don't know if it's a gun or
not that looks like a rifle
could be like a monopod or something the
top of it
looks like a mount for camera to me
maybe either way nice photo dumbass
see you in jail [ __ ] idiot
at least antifa knows to cover their
face when they're doing crime that's the
main way that you know it's not antifa
right
on issues like vaccines and the absence
from this is the president united states
correct that is
why not he's the president he's been
left out of this public statement
illustrating the decision made
by the vice president on this oh wait
and that is an exercise of power
to enlarge the law enforcement presence
to quell this uprising
the senior most member of the trump
administration to ratify that was the
vice president
that gets us a little bit farther down
the road operationally
to this conversation we were just having
about who's exercising power
the vice president just exercised power
in consultation with the bipartisan
leadership
of the united states congress and the
chairman of the joint trustee just
posted their nudes
on twitter you gotta love that
yo god [ __ ] me she's like totally i'm
sorry trish about oh god
she posted this on twitter i just
thought it was oh my god [ __ ] dude
you see that damn fans feed every day
um i just think it's funny i just have
breaking news trisha just posted her
nudes on twitter doesn't she do that all
the time
well it's just a funny timing 25 minutes
ago she's posting her news that's funny
right
breaking news that's all that's my point
she's just trying to spread some love
during this time right yeah
let's see she brings more than love so
united and sweet i just saw the pictures
but there was planning i looked on the
website
of this organization to stop this deal
to
bring this protest which was organized
primarily by women for trump is the
primary organizing
um avenue among many others i imagine
that's just a fundraising vehicle
for that particular group i kind of want
to keep going to cover this but
i think we should let the dogs out and
get some food and stuff
yeah i want to do like i don't know how
do we wrap this
up do you mind um taking the doggies out
for today
okay i just feel bad but i think we'll
go to like probably
5 if that's okay with you guys because
that's when
we have to take theodore so i cannot go
past five
i'm right or die okay let's go to 5 a.m
i would go live i would go all night if
i could but
we are hasan now yeah i am i am hassan
hassan ain't [ __ ] i got a little head
it's my head's smaller than his son back
the [ __ ] off
maybe i can go all night if he puts
theodore to bed tonight
i would like [ __ ] to go home at some
point yeah
well uh you work for me no i'm kidding
yeah of course i understand
but maybe you can just what maybe
i'm sorry so this is historic it's
historic no
i'm just saying uh you want some food i
could order you food
uh i mean if we're really gonna be going
for a while we should maybe you want
hummus i bought hummus
i love hummus okay we got some really
good homes there's a place nearby
that's off the chain let's [ __ ] go
but
uh it was here in dc
where they'll draw a line they'll mess
up and then you'll start hearing me move
back
move back and they'll establish because
i want to hear apparently they're going
to get in there and try to
vote again so i actually really want to
see what happens
yeah that's what they said huh people
away from the capitol him ask we need to
go this way here you're going to hit a
fence
we're moving back here further back from
the capitol uh you know
these sort of things are pretty
commonplace in dc where there's a
demonstration and dc police need to move
people around you know
uh it's basically every day of the week
there's somebody yelling at a building
in washington
uh so this sort of thing is is actually
what the dc police
know how to do they do it very well and
they are they are moving the trump
supporters
uh mass you can see there are still some
of the trump flags and things up ahead
here that we're
we're walking towards as we're being uh
being moved along by the dc police
and where are you right now chris
national guard the dc sure
so we are uh we're right at first and
we'll be first in
delaware or so right by the uh the
reflecting pond that's in front of the
west front of the capital
um that's still pretty close to the
capital
got it still pretty close uh to the
capitol but certainly backed off of the
perimeter no doubt
um yes absolutely and the crowd has
gotten smaller nora i think that's
important to note the dc national guard
are on scene here we have people in
military uniforms with shields
that are part of this law enforcement
action that's
pushing that sounds like it's done
there's right like i don't think they're
gonna be able to
now that the national guard's there and
they got the riot shields there
they got the big boys there now
[Music]
probably hopefully
this is so weird
guys it's so bizarre got down to the
west front
we were looking at people scaling the
scaffolding
up to the area where the inauguration
will be
that then led to people breaching the
capital
uh and we know that that once people got
inside that turned deadly where a woman
lost her life after being shot inside
the capitol and just some remarkable
images
of capital police barricading the house
chamber
and with their guns drawn as people were
apparently attempting to get inside the
house chamber where members of congress
were working
uh you know and it has continued for
hours now
i want to draw your attention here in
north carolina you see this in the
discord sorry
well the dc i don't know i didn't know
zach was down there
yeah i saw that little guy zach how do
you explain this
what are you doing dude oh cp how do you
explain this
guilty man got him you know i gotta go
where you know chaos is
all right tell me if there's any
developments i'll keep i'll try i'll try
to keep entertaining
you know because we got actually a show
here
you know
say what we're live right now god
forgot yeah we're live dude we're not
just sitting here watching the news
james charles you guys want me to to
slam on james charles and me the people
always i mean look writing is bad but
have you seen what james charles has
been tweeting
i feel so stupid now it's like the state
capital is under siege
and james charles just tweeted
uh this seems so stupid i don't really
don't even give a [ __ ]
like seriously i'm talking about james
having beef with this girl jen
mcallister
like who cares cause the [ __ ]
here trump farts during call with
georgia's secretary of state
now we're talking business that's true
you guys all heard this infamous call
probably by now where trump is called
to georgia secretary of state and he
says infamously like all i need is 11
000 votes you know
but did you guys know that on that call
trump ripped ass what oh thank you this
is perfect yeah he ripped ass
he had a wendy williams moment what so
here listen
yeah no the guys found did you guys find
her or was just going around the
internet it had
been going around but not that much yeah
i haven't heard anything okay so he
ripped ass on the call now listen
closely okay
first listen here
to be able to develop no we do have a
way but i don't want to get into it
have we found a way another states
leader excuse me but we don't need it
because we're only down 11
000 votes so we don't even need it dan
do you want a beverage
i'm okay you want this watermelon drink
you can have mine it's okay
you want it don't you i i'm really okay
okay
okay drink dan it's okay
so so listen closely he says right
before he says excuse me listen no
develop no we do have a way but i don't
want to get into it
exactly have we found a way another
states leader excuse me
but we don't it's very subtle now and it
says excuse
me so yeah now no zach you isolated it
right
correct okay now let me know warning he
talks over the fart
just fair warning okay
found a way enough
isolated i mean i hear it but like it's
one of those things once you hear it you
won't be able to not hear it
what i don't hear anything just listen
under his voice
guys i don't hear anything really you
don't hear that
am i crazy does that mean i'm not
totally surprised you can't hear it
it's super subtle but it is there a
minor fart
issue that's not part of our case it's
not part of
we we just didn't feel as though we had
any way
to be able to develop no we do have a
way but i don't want to get into it
have we found a way another states
leader excuse me
because we're only down 11 thousand
votes like we don't even
kind of like yeah really gross
found a way enough but yeah i don't hear
it there do you yeah me neither
i don't know why are you sure you got it
yes 100
i'm hearing it every time i think i need
more i need more
people are saying that it's more really
okay play it again play it again
found a way another i don't know what
[ __ ] i just heard it's like
it's literally right on it what can i
tell you i don't
hear it i need more before and after try
and give him a little i guess
just give me a little fart i need some
context do you hear this
that's a fart that's one yeah yes zach i
hear that
okay great experiment zach
you want to play more fart sound effects
and see if i'm registering it
well some people can't hear certain
frequencies damn exactly you know i can
hear that fart we played it a billion
someone in the chest had boomer ears
boomer ears [ __ ] you guys everybody
probably it probably is easier with
headphones which which i'm wearing right
now and i hear it very clearly
uh but give me give me a little before i
edit it and this is important needs a
little more handling country is under
siege and this is
incriminating we're putting trump on
trial here
criminal flatulence
he's working on it i don't hear
anything it's these speakers i don't
have boomer ears come here to be honest
i don't hear it either i only
heard it in the full clip yeah yeah
okay well everybody else can hear it but
it's not that fun for me i wish i could
hear him rip an ass
it needs more zak more before and after
more
more okay i'll pull it give me a minute
thank you chad's saying they hear it
yeah
i don't know yeah boomer ear is
like a big [ __ ] ass yeah it's it's
like distant
but you can tell it's a huge fart but
it's like far away
it's almost like he didn't even try he
was like excu like he just fought and
there's a room he's in a room full of
people
he's awesome he just ripped ass i think
he [ __ ] himself
you think he should no it sounds really
wet
i'm afraid a lot of the chat heard me
when i was doing the fake fart with my
mouth
because i think a lot of them said they
are you [ __ ] it up baby
i think you farted for real
kim and kanye are divorcing yadda yadda
drinks new haircuts pretty good
you all seen this everybody was goofing
on well i guess throw it up first and
then all
oh there's a new link by ian what do you
got here for us ian
good afternoon from washington state
capitol building
[Music]
protesters are now standing outside of
government j's mansion
this is in washington state i assume
oh man i don't know anything about some
whoever's making those maga signs or
making a killing
how much you want to bet all those maga
flags are made in china
probably made a billion dollars
[Applause]
although i don't know if you there's
another video that i've thrown to
ethan yeah i can open that ela okay so
you
just sent me this is a tweet from july
of this
of last year anarchist agitators or
protesters who vandalize or damage our
federal
courthouse in portland or any federal
building in any of our cities or states
will be prosecuted under our recently
reenacted statutes and monuments act
minimum 10 years in prison don't do it
oh good i'm glad we have a lot that's
applicable to these people
at the same time only 13 is trending
because only 13 people
they removed this tweet oh they ran it
they must be watching our uh yeah
hey hey jack thanks jack you said only
13 is trendy
yeah because everyone is like why only
13 were arrested
wait you know they said there was for
comparison apparently there was 14
000 arrests during the george floyd
protests
yep only 13 that's crazy
these cops a lot of they all support
trump
i mean they're they're kind of on their
side that's why they're
walking them down the steps gently ma'am
not all obviously but
yeah taking photos and [ __ ]
but i gotta believe it to see it let me
go over to trump's twitter i sent his
profile link that is gone
wow so actually i'm kind of
i'm kind of confused oh yeah no longer
available
i'm kind of confused about like how all
these lunatics are gonna respond
now you know because it's like
now the censorship is real now what's
really happening
the overthrow is real what does it mean
that we have a president whose tweets
are so violent and
reprehensible that twitter and facebook
are deleting them off their platform
what is
like literally what not only that people
are begging them to delete it
i think their thought process and
probably one that
i understand is like if we erase it it's
already out there it's just gonna drive
people even crazier but
at the same time it's like
can you imagine if they just banned him
from twitter he would lose everything
twitter is like his whole world right
oh man what a [ __ ] loser
how the fart if uh hit me with the farts
let's try it one more time okay
i don't want to get into it have we
found a way another thing i heard it i
heard it that was a juicy one
we found a way another state hit it now
you want the full clip yeah i don't want
to get into it
dude it does sound like he [ __ ] himself
so juicy wait mike pence's header
changed
oh it did change on twitter probably
because because people were thinking it
was uh
he changed his banner yeah mike i need
it
right let me look at mike pence's yeah
i just checked it look the same to me
but yeah a lot of people are saying that
no i see a different one you know what
he has two profiles yeah people are
probably getting confused he has two
twitters
almost all politicians have two because
they have an official one
exactly they have an official and a
personal so thank you i'm glad he's not
on twitter [ __ ] around this banner at
this time
yeah okay evidently he is
the acting commander-in-chief right now
so he's probably got more
you mean just based on this yeah i mean
yeah well i don't know
yeah this report that i wasn't sure if
you heard something it does it does seem
to be more
because it was just a few news sources
but i saw uh
uh what do you call it associated press
and stuff confirming that he was the one
to uh to order the national guard in
so i mean the vice president does not
have the power
to do that yeah so that that is the vice
president doesn't really have power to
do
anything unless the president's income
stated so it's very telling
have breached the gates of the
governor's man mansion
what now
[Applause]
i mean look this is this is this is
reaping what you sell to fox news the
news max
to [ __ ] aon to all these
personalities online to all the gop
all the republicans the bow to him when
you tell
people that the election was stolen that
it's a fraud
this is what you expect to happen yeah
and frankly if that
is what happened this would be justified
but it's not
he's stealing that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the usa champs jesus [ __ ] rights
[Applause]
i mean on one hand it's like
if they sincerely believe the election
was stolen so they're
you know what i mean but ted cruz knows
it wasn't
ted cruz a [ __ ] lawyer he went to
harvard you know that
with the harvard law he's very educated
very smart he knows the election was
legit
right
at the capitol on 9 11 perhaps pair back
the number of states that they want to
challenge
and we need to run exactly what's going
to happen
when they're going to resume until those
lawmakers have made their decision
and conveyed it to the house speaker the
first time i've ever heard dan using the
best senate's republican leader mitch
mcconnell
you described how lawmakers almost
fearful
for their lives for their safety on
capitol hill to see the sergeant of arms
directing the capitol police
with guns drawn to protect the house
floor there
and hearing from senator tammy duckworth
today that a quick thinking aid
decided to gather the electoral votes
which now i understand are in that
secure location
with the lawmakers that's right and so
if this process resumes again tonight
they will continue
going over those for certification
documents and one by one confirming
that either joe biden or donald trump
won
various states and then counting up
those votes nora this is normally a
routine process
four years ago it lasted 35
minutes and the person who was presiding
was none other than vice president she
said last year democrats
last year this lasted 35 minutes angry
staffer
go to oh i didn't send you a specific
tweet
um here i think you did i clicked the
wrong thing
this is a complete security nightmare in
addition to the building being trashed
who knows what
was left behind by the writers of what
was accessed on these systems
whoa read that i am inside nancy
pelosi's office with the thousands of
revolutionaries who have stormed the
building
who is this guy to put this in
perspective how quickly staff evacuated
emails are still on the screen alongside
a federal alert warning members of the
current revolution
who the [ __ ] is who is this guy
elijah schaefer of course i don't know
you should read this dan
i'm seeing it right now yeah
the cops just let them in someone said
pretty much
dude these people do not realize what
they're doing
you just took a photo oh i haven't seen
that this is ten minutes ago
send me that and what's his name elijah
say for
oh a revolutionary elijah schaefer
some good [ __ ] here these people do not
realize that taking
photograph of nancy pelosi's open email
is not a good idea
[Music]
here apparently is people trying to
fight their way
out of the capitol building
they're crushing them looks like the
revolution ended when the police showed
up
dude they are way too civil to these
people
[Music]
this is so insane nightmare
look at this special forces arrived
[Music]
these guys are not by the way look how
bad i saw these guys look
don't [ __ ] with any of them right and
then
you've got larry
larry the mall cop larry come on dude
just let the guys do their job
larry and moe he's saying
crazy well
it seems to be slowing down the news
doesn't it
at least for now i mean which is good
hopefully they're just
going home it's tried to challenge the
result
president of the united states donald
trump and this violence this grotesque
lawless spectacle
the united states capital is direct
there is
no ambiguity about that the president
mere moments before this happened
said in a speech to these very people
that the election was stolen
and that they had to at least we see him
for what he is now
inciting violence directly twitter is
now just straight up deleting his tweets
something has never happened before
the mask is off everybody sees
also pretty literally all these people
don't wear a mask
off yeah exactly learn from antifa now
all you idiots will be in jail hopefully
before trump pardons them all real quick
i hereby pardon all the special people
who stormed the capital
you know i'm glad at least that it's
made pretty
clear to everybody it should be about
what we're dealing with here
you know if there's anything very
special it's like you're debating all
the time with people about who is this
guy donald trump and what does he mean
what's he stand for it's pretty [ __ ]
clear now
i feel like at this point this type of
supporters that you see
on there are like actual just cult
members
i feel like there's got to be a lot of
his original voters that
are seeing him for what he is i agree no
no for sure
100 yeah i think it's i think it's
overall
i think that is a good thing i think
that as i was saying a lot of the people
who are supporting him are not going to
be able to turn a blind eye to this
mm-hmm you know and all these
this is like a mag occult it's not you
know
not many people i hope are gonna like
show up at the capitol ready to
i mean how many people like 70 million
people voted for him so
only need a small fraction of people
from that to get charged up
do something about from mayor bowser
that being announced from the pentagon
the acting secretary
noting that that was made in
consultation with the vice president and
leaders of congress
notably absent from that conversation
was president
trump which has raised eyebrows but it
looks now
like this is going to move forward on on
the capitol yeah there's still a lot of
activity on the streets of dc please
keep the vote there that would be so bad
for some 45 minutes now so let's bring
in cbs news chief justice and homeland
security correspondent
jeff piguets and jeff i know you've been
there all day what have you learned
you know trump's just angry that twitter
erased his tweet that's all he cares
about right now
censorship big tech is censoring us
that's the problem with america
hey excuse me uh apparently chuck
schumer
said that they're planning to resume
their counting at eight o'clock
oh mama you know what god bless them
that's heroic that is so um
that's badass [ __ ] you we are finishing
this eight o'clock what time is it there
that's like an
hour right uh that'd be five o'clock our
time so
yeah yeah hour 15 minutes
i want to be there for it i gotta be
there for it right
i can't leave i think it's gonna be too
long
we're in so deep
[Laughter]
i mean i could talk let me kill some
time here we could talk about uh
drake's hair you know uh zach
tell your uh p diddy story please we got
a story
do you want to look at zach's heart what
is this yeah zach you have a p diddy
star what's going on zach
so i was telling ian um oh my
right my my foreskin
from my bris is in p diddy's backyard
okay let me take that in for a moment
so okay hold on let me
you want me to explain or do you want to
think about it okay so let me let me ask
some questions here
why where were you okay yeah let's start
with
what let's let's start with why
okay so before p diddy owned the house
my
grandfather owned the house and i had my
bris there
circa 1997. they just throw it in the
garden
no they bury it like there's some
jewish i mean it's almost barbaric you
know in a way but you know it's cleaner
um but we're discussing we're not here
to discuss the circumcision
so when i was circumcised they buried it
in the backyard
my grandfather passed away about 10
years ago
the kid sold the house he wasn't my
blood grandfather
but my grandmother was married to him
and who i referred to as my grandfather
so it was this house and you know when
he passed away the kids sold the house
and um he did he bought the house
and so my foreskin vis-a-vis
peted his backyard and funny enough his
son
was in my graduating class and there was
one time where
because the kid was kind of a dick like
i'm not going really if he didn't didn't
raise him right huh
so we got into it once you say i got my
pee diddy in your yard [ __ ]
got him um and um
i'm like yeah well my [ __ ] foreskins
in your backyard
oh my god that's just like a weird
statement like you're weird
you could never imagine that was true
yeah so my foreskins in his backyard
i'd like it back
you know there's procedures where people
try to regrow their foreskin
by like stretching it out and stuff yeah
there's like contraptions
that you put on your dick and you wear
it all day and like stretch
your dick skin to create a new horse
no swear on swear on it
uh a b are you circumcised that's arabs
do that right muslims
yes yeah we have so much in common
i know i always why do we
i know i always say there's no two
people more similar but
i'm gonna get killed now but it's true i
mean just on the just on the papers like
circumcised yes hummus yes
big yes you know falafel yes
need that go on although you guys love
something that you guys love that the
jews can't get down with it's
interesting because i always see it on
like um turkish tick tock and stuff
is they drown me in cheese
oh yeah they do yeah they yeah we do
like cheese there's like cheese desserts
yeah yes the dairy and it's the dairy
and meat
those guys get weird with that but yeah
the jews don't get down with the dairy
and the
meat it takes some adjusting it's not
kosher so we don't have that in common
maybe but
so much more you guys want to talk about
drake's haircut
yeah what is this why does he look like
justin bieber
there's no way he thought that looked
good right like no way
i feel like it's it's got to be for a
music video or something like i don't
think it's serious
so but he he tweeted or he did a story
and he was like vibes
vibe check or whatever and people
started clowning on me and he erased it
so i don't know
yeah the erasing the erasing is bizarre
it's a straight smosh cut
i mean ian you probably have some intel
on this what's the scope
i mean i i'm with dan i think it's
probably a music video thing
his album is meant to come out this
month right
why didn't he's called racist it's
called certified lover boy
that kind of explains the picture what a
horrible name though isn't it
i'm kind of cringy yeah yeah a little
bit
i hate it so much
yeah he erased it kind of a ben affleck
tattoo move right
yeah and this this one's kind of
unrelated this just showed up on my feed
on tick tock and maybe you guys will
enjoy it
this is a dude on tv just wild bro
he's this is in case you want to follow
him his name is user2274609096292
his sim similar name to our uh our joe
biden
oh for real yeah he was also a user plus
a lot of numbers
he's pretty active on here all he does
is make videos looking at the camera
his name is muhammad oh that was good
look at this every video is the same
it's so epic
he's so epic man look at this [ __ ] every
time every video oh he's going to say
something
oh no he listens to country music i
would never guess
i would never guess he's listening to
long-haired country boys who sounds kind
of gay
not that there's anything wrong with it
but never long-haired country boys the
name of a song it sounds like a
you know what i mean someone asked that
we talk about the weekend
face makeup and i didn't hear about it
so here's something if you want to look
into it
i thought this was just a filter and now
it's
for anyone who follows the weekend
because i'm a big weekend fan i mean for
a long time
he's always every time he has a new
album he kind of has a new theme
so that's why the last awards show he
was wrapped in bandages and this is
for him too i got it but he's been
wearing it for months
no i don't think he's no he hasn't
that's what the article says it's saying
he's been wearing the jarring makeup and
appearances for months
oh yeah he had appearances yeah i
suppose yeah he's just part of the album
cycle
yeah he looks good he's got that he's
got that handsome squidward
do you sin for the weekend too on the
weekend my favorite artist
favorite artist hands down yep huh okay
yeehaw is that okay with all of you guys
i have a problem i have a slightly
different don't mind it just let me
think about it
yeah i'll think about it favorite artist
i mean that's a strong statement to make
better than kanye
shots fired have you written a movie
script about kanye or anything like that
you mean about the weekend about the
weekend well i was just yeah about the
weekend
yeah we know ian has order on the
streets
as this curfew is set in aura
what's the music the gays thank you so
much
and thank you want to bring in o'keeffe
and
major garrett because what all the
pundits are coming out i can't do it i
hate when they bring out the pundits
i watch the news sometimes and they go
they bring out new people and they talk
about the same [ __ ] all [ __ ] night
it's crazy well i don't know if there's
anything
left else to say i think this is going
gonna go over fine the next one i'm
happy they're doing it it's pretty pimp
pretty baller and i'm happy they're
doing it you know
i'll be watching on the news that's for
sure yeah man this is gonna there's just
gonna be a lot of interesting
[ __ ] to follow because what's gonna
happen with trump
he's still in office for 14 more days oh
charlie kirk i guess
what this [ __ ] is saying well this is
this is an old tweet but it's just it's
pretty good
this guy's such a piece of dog [ __ ]
hey liberals do you notice that when
conservatives lose races we don't riot
scream smash windows burn cars assault
people or need days off of work
nice it's amazing how mature and civil
conservatives are
please remember this and take notes when
we get trump reelected
oh by the way he goes re-elected garbage
that's beautiful yeah this was two years
ago oh by the way so he's turning point
usa that's the that's where that one
congress lady was speaking where she
said hitler got one thing right
perfect it was his organization he's the
guy with the uh with the little face
small face big gums
we love it folks here's another one of
those types of tweets
i feel that um this was very special so
we
yeah what's next live i hope i don't
miss anything i'll have to jump on live
again
hey donald if donald trump were to lose
he won't
i love that oh and all their
hypothetical situations where they're so
gracefully
they're so graceful it's always he won't
lose
and we will always win if real donald
trump were to lose he won't his
supporters will go back to work tomorrow
just as we do every day when biden loses
his supporters will likely loot and riot
tells you everything you need to know
well it's someone just from 36 minutes
ago hey i mean
technically they did go back to work the
next day
try it two months later it's a different
story
they're stealing it yeah there's gonna
be a lot of
there's going to be a lot of interesting
developments this is going to be very
interesting next two weeks because
i mean first of all we're going to see
how this vote goes
i think it's just going to go peacefully
i'd love to see if all these pieces of
shits
like ted cruz are going to actually
still try to dispute the results
you know that's going to be interesting
to watch
and then
we got i don't know is he he's kind of
just has to leave
i feel like he's got to leave he only
has two weeks left but
the thing is if you impeach him he can't
run again because i know he keeps
talking about running at 2024.
i don't think that's ever going to work
because he's going to be so [ __ ] old
then
i don't think it will work again because
he lost now and
i think now the you know the image is
just shattered especially after this
it's not going to work again
yeah the first time there was this hope
that maybe
you know it's like a gamble but now a
lot of people know it didn't work
you look so bomb your hair looks so
great
thank you i love how it came out and the
sweater looks great you look really good
people asked if we plan to restock it
and um we will because
there's been a lot of demand so
there's gonna be a few pieces that we're
gonna restock
and i think that's going to be fine so
um i guess that's it i mean i really do
i
think i think we've we've reached the
natural conclusion of this
we'll be back tomorrow live though we're
going to do after dark so who knows if
the country's on fire again not tomorrow
night
friday tomorrow's thursday oh right well
we can come back tomorrow if it's all
wild
i was planning to work on teddy fresh
well you don't have to be here okay
we'll see how it goes
hopefully i'm hoping we don't come back
tomorrow we're on riot watch
we're on civil war watch i'm scratching
my head about this
pence situation yeah like the weirdest
part of all this time i'm honestly just
gonna go sit in front of
the news and read and try to figure out
what the [ __ ] going on
because trump still has two weeks in
office and i'm not really sure how
that's going to work
yeah i mean there's a lot of people
calling for him to resign and uh
he's not going to resign yeah zero
percent chance of that happening
but i'm not even sure he's gonna leave
in two weeks
one way or another is gonna be taken out
of there
this was not helpful to him though this
this was a disaster for everybody this
is just a huge
loss for everybody let me check ted or
one more time before we log off
twitter theater oh
people keep asking about ski jacket says
ab
um the ski jackets we will have to bring
back next winter because i think
by the time we'll have it back it won't
be cold anymore
so um that's that but there's gonna be a
lot of beanies soon
we got some really cool beanies coming
out in february
i am for the record against fascism just
to say
that's good i'm anti-fascism
for the record you can write that down
ethan klein is against fascism and i'm
not afraid to say it
so brave
it's weird though yeah it's weird what
would it be
i'm sorry the delay always messes me up
i'm just saying people are saying this
is historic people are going to use this
footage whenever they talk about the
first time
uh twitter deleted a trim uh tweet
is this the first time twitter's erased
a tweet
of the president or the president thank
you so much the president
only has two weeks left so maybe they'll
just go on it maybe let's see
let's see where i mean i mean who how do
you top this it's going to be
off the [ __ ] rails
mike's got my glue all right well
all right well thanks for joining us i
mean this was wild is there any other
comments you want to read
before we leave um
let's see i have a few of them they're
all just pretty much thanking you guys
people saying thank you thank you for
coming on live for this it's really good
to have laughs with you that's
crazy i appreciate that thank you sam
for us
dan the head of national security nsc i
assume his national security account
stated he conferred with pence on the
return of congress the capital head of
nsc answers the president yeah i mean
i feel like something happened behind
the scenes and they're not saying
because it would probably set people off
way more right they might have
it doesn't they might have pulled the
plug on his on his power i feel like
i really want to believe that because
that's what should happen but i feel so
sick
yeah exactly after this year like
nothing ever happens
you know but it's like now when there's
14 days left you're going to pull the
plug on and it's just going to make
things worse and more complicated but
this was a real
i mean this was really wrong i agree on
something then
it raises the question like how does
this happen like what i don't know what
is the actual
mechanism in which you pull the plug on
the president the fact that he didn't
bring that but do you vote like how do
you
the vice president with half of the
cabinet
can effectively depose the president wow
if he doesn't bring the national guard
like what are his priorities
no i agree i'm just curious about the
mechanic so i'd love to know if that's
what happened
there's a very specific uh there's a
very specific method for doing it that's
laid out in the constitution in the 25th
amendment so if mike pence and half the
cabinet is like we got to pull the plug
and i think
there might be some other parties that
need to be involved but yeah it's it's
for
if the president has lost his mind and
he's
trying to nuke you know new york city or
something they
they have a way to overthrow him i could
see trump doing that
yeah i'm just using that as an extreme
example but i mean
like you said the vice president doesn't
have power like he can't
yeah command troops i don't know why the
media's
talking about it more because like
because i i almost feel like they're
afraid to because i mean that maybe
that's really good i mean if that really
happened that's gonna when is the media
afraid to say anything that will just
get them watches and clicks
generally very responsible but somebody
tweeted out that it was mike pence this
this to me is the biggest mystery
yeah it's very weird very weird let me
see what's trending
like i saw twenty-fifth and something
like
trending someone said i said you guys um
made me feel safe watching this or
something like that and he wrote
he had to take down his pride flag
oh that's horrible this is worried and
that's so sad that is so sad dude
yeah i i'm proud of you i love you
you are not hated somebody said where is
a b emote do we not have an ab
emote i thought i'm sorry that you're
feeling so
you're feeling that i mean that's just
tragic no we don't they always uh
spam it i thought we i swear to god we
made one oh maybe it's only in the
discord and not on
youtube yet discard we have yeah we got
to fix that exactly we got to get the a
b mode
going fallout 3 is trending is this
some kind of weird joke or we'll fall
out three takes places
oh my god there's pictures of fallout 3
in the state capital and it looks it's
just like
it's set in dc oh my goodness crazy
well
i didn't know what to say i'm i'm
just hopefully the rest of the night
goes good you know goes through
and uh maybe we'll be back tomorrow if
there's more insanity
so just everybody have a good night try
to relax
everyone stay home and just stay safe
yeah i wouldn't recommend going out
just anywhere definitely not especially
with kovid just
just this every i feel like
ultimately this is a turning point where
everyone's going to see this for what it
is
and even the people who are republican
who have supported trump of the
republican party to this point
are going to understand that it's time
to put a stop to this
and that this will be a turning point
towards a peaceful transition and that
you know things will start to get back
to normal a little bit here
so that's my hope
i hope it's a nice calmer night
and uh if it's insane we'll be back
tomorrow and if it's not
then we'll be back on friday live for
after dark
but stay safe guys okay
hell of a year already huh yeah we're
off to a great start to me this is still
2020. yeah like i said
2021 starts january 20th
yeah this is part of the same [ __ ]
of 2020. i'm not going to blame this
year yet
i'm not writing this year off yet it
deserves a chance
you know what i mean well we did have
some good news with
uh the votes so
georgia yeah so i do think 2021 is
it's got a good start oh my god
oh my god
all right guys have a fantastic night
take it easy
we'll definitely see on friday at the
least okay
[Music]
four hours huh three
three hours we've been streaming
[Music]
and just remember
hitler had one thing right
[Laughter]
if i have anything to say it was that
hitler had one thing right
now you can definitely cut that up the
youth
if you got the youth you've got the
future
[Music]
come on boys bring your confederate flag
and you're burning crosses let's get
them
hey joe did you pack your noose don't
forget your noose now
yeah we maggot boys ain't nothing like
antifa
antifa scum wait nothing like that grab
that podium
oh ian has something what do you got ian
something good uh trump's
account will be locked for the next 12
hours
[Music]
where did you read that uh twitter lock
them up
give me that link give me that
[ __ ] link locked out bro baby
link me now
that [ __ ] can't use twitter what a
[ __ ] loser
i don't like it i don't like it i can
use twitter
i foolishly started the music and it's
nearing me let's just restart it
it's a good vibe as a result of the
unprecedented ongoing violence situation
in washington dc
we have acquired the removal of three
donald trump tweets that were posted
earlier today for repeated and severe
violation
of our thick integrity policy
this means that the account of real
donald trump will be locked for 12 hours
following the removal of these tweets
if the tweets are not removed the
account will remain locked
so he has to go in and erase it himself
their race of shame go erase your
tweets and shame [ __ ] i like that
he may have that means that he probably
deleted those not them
the ones that we saw no they said they
removed them they said
they said we required oh you're right
they said we required
in the follow-up it says if the tweets
are not removed the account will remain
locked
[Music]
you think this was this happened and
then he removed them no but this just
they just tweeted this is did you guys
see the one that says future violations
will
result in permanent suspension for real
damage
let's [ __ ] go dude trump without
twitter is nothing do you understand how
how nothing he'll be imagine him on
parlor like oh my god
i mean one more violation that's easy he
does one like they
like well they've never done this before
so and he's done some pretty heinous
[ __ ]
oh and then it says future violations of
the twitter rules
including our civic integrity or violent
threats policies will result in
permanent suspension
that's what we just said yeah can we
just write that event
try and keep up with the world peace
did you guys hear that uh kanye and
jeffrey star hooked up
you think you think i wonder if jeff
gives good
um check back
you know i've i've been giving links for
three hours straight
thank you yeah we're just giving a [ __ ]
you've been crushing it
yeah thank you thank you
you take my job today you see it's
happened to me
get that mayo ian do you think jeffree
star gives good neck
nick let's just end it now
is that the stream all right and then
left here easy
well there you watch tv i'll also be
playing some
now let's just send it okay and i'm
starting the music
all right back the second time round two
round two of wrapping it up
from tati thank you everybody for being
here with us it was
really nice that everyone that we could
all do this together because
i wasn't gonna do a show i was just
gonna sit at home and kind of like
rage or not rage watch but maybe like
doom watch maybe
doom watch so it's better to do watch
together
um someone asked what hair brand do i
use
because uh sincerely a girl who doesn't
want to break
my hair off so i have news for you my
hair broke off last week
and i got i'm missing a lot of hair on
the back
but luckily it's kind of hard to see
because it was in the back
but it looks so healthy it really does
so yeah
i don't actually know what brand i don't
remember
maybelline yeah i don't know that's just
the one i always hear on the commercials
it's maybelline maybe she's born with it
is that the one where they're having
orgasms in the shower no that's herbal
essence
[Music]
and then they go i'll have what she's
having right yeah i think so
all right all right i'm ending it i'm
gonna go have some dinner guys we'll
we'll see uh we'll see tomorrow or
friday tomorrow on friday
god bless god bless super trooper nation
foot army
i'm ethan klein seven on wiki feet see
you guys next time
[Music]
you